[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on y va
la localisation
[Musique]
mais d'abord moi j'ai je continue mes
déplacements dans toute la France
j'étais dans l'Orne lundi et je ressens
pas du tout d'essoufflement parmi la
population et surtout parmi les salariés
il y a toujours la même colère le même
rejet de cette réforme qui s'ajoute à
l'inflation les prix de l'énergie le
prix de l'essence et donc il y a un tout
et la cocotte elle est en train de
bouillir toujours
et donc cette journée de mobilisation
est une journée de plus je regrette que
le gouvernement s'entête
le prochain rendez-vous c'est maintenant
le 7 mars et je salue le choix de la
terre syndicale d'avoir décidé de mettre
la France à l'arrêt pour se faire
entendre malheureusement il faut passer
par là et cette décision c'est une
décision historique
exceptionnelle qui ne s'est pas produite
depuis plusieurs décennies et c'est dire
la gravité de la situation dans notre
pays
intelligence et faire d'argent c'est
toujours très fort mais bien sûr que
c'est dur pour les salariés pour les
salariés du privé comme du public de se
mettre en grève de perdre une
demi-journée ou une journée de salaire
c'est dur pour tout le monde mais c'est
encore plus dur de perdre 2 ans de sa
vie à cause de la réforme des retraites
et donc on en est là aujourd'hui on est
dans un combat pour le pour le progrès
social on est surtout sur un combat pour
pas perdre de dents de sa vie dans une
période où c'est dur pour tout le monde
je rencontre des salariés qui sont
menacés de licenciement je rencontre des
salariés qui ont été en première ligne
qui voient pas d'augmentation de salaire
et la seule réponse que fait ce
gouvernement c'est vous allez travailler
deux ans de plus la colère elle est
énorme il y a des entreprises qui sont
prises à la gorge aussi vraiment en ce
moment on a besoin de tout sauf de cette
réforme des retraites et il est
indispensable urgentissime que le
gouvernement l'entende l'univers
syndicaux ils ont choisi aujourd'hui de
manifester à Albi Jean-Luc Mélenchon
était de son côté à Montpellier c'est
dans ces grandes villes de région que ça
se passe aujourd'hui
ce que l'on aille à l'Assemblée
nationale excusez-nous à l'Assemblée
nationale avec le temps contraint et
avec la volonté des groupes de la
majorité de droite qui ne veulent pas en
fait qu'il y ait de vote ils sont des
masqués aujourd'hui ils ne veulent pas
qu'il y ait de vote sur l'article 7 ils
ne veulent pas qu'on y arrive
sur la stratégie de la nupette
concernant les amendements il y a eu
beaucoup beaucoup d'amendements déposés
et puis finalement là en ce moment ils
sont retirés parmi les c'est quoi la
stratégie que vous comment vous comment
vous la comprenez qu'est-ce que vous
défendez moi je vais vous parler de la
stratégie du groupe GDR et des députés
communistes c'est d'aller à l'article 7
nous voulons vite aller à cet article 7
qui est écrit noir sur blanc le report
de l'âge de départ en retraite de 62 à
64 ans nous voulons y aller nous le
disons depuis le début nous avons retiré
tous nos amendements là tous nos
amendements sont retirés nous voulons
aller l'article 7 et puis je vais vous
faire une annonce chez nous dans notre
groupe
tous les députés voteront contre tous
les députés votre rencontre l'article 7
il y aura pas une abstention il manquera
pas une voix nous voterons contre cet
article 7 et chez nous il y a pas
d'ambiguïté j'aimerais bien que d'autres
groupes s'expriment que ce soit chez les
républicains chez les centrices le modem
horizon à Renaissance qu'ils aient le
courage de dire à leurs électeurs ce
qu'ils vont voter ça c'est le courage et
c'est la vérité démocratique
mais le rassemblement national n'a rien
à proposer aux Français le rassemblement
national ne défend pas d'amendement le
rassemblement national n'a fait aucune
proposition la seule proposition du
rassemblement national c'est fait des
enfants c'est la natalité enfin un peu
de sérieux tout ce qu'il demande c'est
de supprimer les cotisations sociales
des entreprises comment on finance la
sécurité sociale en supprimant les
cotisations des entreprises ils n'ont
pas de réponse et donc pour exister pour
exister il dépose une motion de censure
qui va justement allonger le temps de
discussion et peut-être nous priver
d'avoir ce débat et ce vote sur
l'article 7 et donc il contribue aussi
dans une forme de complicité avec le
gouvernement qu'il n'y ait pas de débat
sur l'article 7 et pas de vote sur la
route possède
et bien que le Président de la
République a perdu la France
le président de la République a perdu la
France comment
continuer à fracturer le pays avec une
réforme qui rejetée depuis plusieurs
semaines maintenant avec détermination
avec des hommes et des femmes qui
donnent pour leur pays eux en étant
présent pendant la pandémie en le
faisant tourner quand c'est difficile et
qui le font sans augmentation de salaire
alors que l'inflation est galopante eux
ils sont là la France elle est debout et
elle est là lui il est pas là et c'est
lui qui a perdu le pays
merci à vous est-ce que il y a plein de
choses à jouer à l'Assemblée est-ce que
vous pouvez faire ma rage à plus de
temps dans la vidéo ou est-ce que c'est
en live 14h18 merci beaucoup d'être en
direct une nouvelle fois avec nous pour
suivre cette cinquième journée de
mobilisation on vient d'entendre Fabien
Roussel dans un instant on va regarder
également les images des autres
mobilisations de la journée mobilisation
vous le voyez ici en ce moment donc à
Paris entre la Place de la Bastille et
la place d'Italie qui est le nouveau
tracé du cortège aujourd'hui qu'on va
commenter tout au long de l'après-midi
et on va commencer comme le veut la
tradition désormais avec vous
Marie-Cécile Renaud de du Figaro
économie peut-être une première réaction
à ce qu'on vient d'entendre de la part
de Fabien Roussel avec une volonté de de
d'aller à l'article 7 ce fameux article
7 qui doit décider normalement du report
de l'âge de la retraite à 64 ans c'est
tout à fait
ça alors je vous refais un petit film un
petit
flash-back arrière
la réforme elle a été présentée par
Elisabeth borne et le gouvernement le 10
janvier ensuite elle est passée en
conseil des ministres le 31 elle est
arrivée à l'Assemblée le SI et le 6
février le tout ponctué à chaque fois de
mobilisation
les débats à l'Assemblée doivent prendre
fin vendredi à minuit et ensuite il y a
une période de pause parlementaire des
vacances du 20 au 26 février ensuite le
projet de loi arrivera au Sénat et la
fin de février vers le 27 février c'est
ça jusqu'au 12 mars fin des débats au
Sénat et ensuite il y aura une CMP enfin
des représentants du Sénat et de
l'Assemblée nationale et puis après à
l'issue de cette commission mixte
paritaire
s'il y a un échec soit aussi adopté en
commission mixte paritaire soit c'est un
échec et ça repart à l'Assemblée mais
dans tous les cas les débats doivent
être terminés le 26 à l'Assemblée donc
vous voyez il y a encore encore du
chemin on n'est pas au bout
quand même quelques quelques images donc
de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
en France donc on le voit ici
manifestation à Paris avec un cortège de
la de la CFDT petite parenthèse
d'ailleurs vous qui suivez les questions
sociales la CFDT et une des on peut dire
quand même une des grandes gagnantes de
cette mobilisation en tout cas en termes
de de de d'adhésion syndicale oui alors
effectivement Laurent Berger disait que
en janvier ils ont gagné plus 30% de
d'adhérents et même plus 50% sur les
derniers jours de janvier
alors ils ne sont pas les seuls
apparemment le voilà quand dans des
périodes comme ça de tension sociale
importante et de mobilisation tous les
syndicats
font le plein c'est jackpot pour les
syndicats donc il y a regain de
d'adhésion ça se passe à chaque
manifestation enfin à chaque
mobilisation à chaque grand conflit
social et ça concerne il le disait
lui-même pas simplement la CFDT mais
tous les syndicats alors les syndicats
peut-être aussi les partis politiques on
voit également sur une autre image
Olivier Faure le patron du Parti
socialiste qui également dans la
manifestation on le on l'écoutera si il
prend la parole la spécificité
aujourd'hui c'est que
on vient de l'entendre les leaders
syndicaux et les leaders politiques ne
marchent pas ensemble non vous voulez
dire les syndicats sont à Albi voilà je
vous laisse le dire alors on va
peut-être écouter Olivier fort et puis
on va revenir justement sur cette
mobilisation de syndicats en région on y
reviendra juste après cette déclaration
d'Olivier fort
ement de sa
concerne syndical aura définir les
moyens d'action pour pouvoir faire plier
le gouvernement et arriver à un carnet
cette opposition qui est
ultra majoritaire en France et qui doit
se faire entendre parce qu'à l'évidence
il n'a pas de majorité sociale dans ce
pays enfin c'était cette réforme là
déblocage c'est moyen de faire bouger
les choses c'est pas à moi de le dire en
fait on est très respectueux de ce
qu'est le mois syndical il y a un état
syndicale qui est uni c'est suffisamment
rare pour le souligner et donc c'est
d'abord à eux de définir quels sont les
mots d'ordre qu'ils donnent au monde
syndical et plus largement au monde
salariés et nous nous sommes là pour
accompagner et faire notre job à
l'Assemblée arriver à faire comme nous
le faisons depuis 15 jours maintenant à
démasquer article après article les
mensonges du gouvernement sur les 1200
euros sur les femmes qui seront les
principales victimes sur le caractère
complètement incroyable enfin selon
qu'on est né une épée ou un père on a 43
ou 44 années de cotisations à fournir
sur les financements alternatifs qui
existent plutôt que cette impôt sur la
vie que veut prélever le gouvernement
bref tout ça c'est notre job et puis le
job des syndicats c'est effectivement de
conduire un mouvement social qui est un
mouvement social assez inédit et très
important le plus grand depuis des
années
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un peu avec les vacances scolaires
est-ce que vous redoutez
lundi est-ce que pour vous c'était
important quand même de marquer le coup
aujourd'hui avant notamment l'échéance
de cette mars oui c'est une façon de
maintenir la mobilisation ça va être
très bien qu'aujourd'hui elle serait
plus faible parce qu'il y a les vacances
pour une part de territoire et puis tout
simplement parce que les syndicats ont
déjà appelé à la grève générale le 7
mars il faut comprendre que pour
beaucoup d'entre eux c'est un sacrifice
important c'est déjà la troisième
journée de grève il y a le 4 mouvements
mais enfin c'est la troisième journée de
grève ça coûte dans les poches de chacun
dans un moment d'inflation donc tous ces
gens qui se préparent à la grève
générale ça va aussi que ça va être
difficile et donc je pense qu'elle a
beaucoup aussi qui hésite à faire grève
aujourd'hui pour se préparer pour ce
grand mouvement du 7 mars
[Musique]
plus en région qui apparaît c'est un
mouvement de Bill moyenne comme beaucoup
dit c'est un mouvement qui est national
et donc partout les Français manifestent
et c'est vrai que on voit des villages
où on manifeste on voit des villes
moyennes on n'avait jamais manifesté ou
manifeste dans des proportions assez
incroyables voilà donc Olivier fort le
National des parties socialistes qui a
répondu aux questions j'aimerais bien
justement qu'on revienne sur certains
points qui vient d'avoir des notamment
sur les les
minimas à 1200 euros et sur les ce qu'il
dit également au niveau des femmes mais
d'abord
Marie-Cécile où en est-on actuellement
de la loi de la discussion sur la loi en
dépendamment de toutes les contestations
on va y revenir tout au long de
l'après-midi mais vraiment aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans ce que je vous
disais donc vendredi vendredi minuit les
débats doivent s'arrêter à l'Assemblée
vous me parliez de l'article 7
effectivement
il y a une volonté d'arriver à cet
article 7 qui est l'article central
celui qui porte la mesure d'âge que tout
le monde tous les 7 cas sont opposés le
report de l'âge de l'égal de départ de
63 64 ans et ce que les oppositions
veulent c'est montrer qu'elles sont
contre contre ce report de l'âge donc
c'est pour ça qu'elles veulent arriver à
cet article avant la fin des débats pour
qu'il y a un vote négatif mais elles ont
ils ont quand même supprimé
il reste il reste 11000 amendements à
discuter et du coup pour accélérer un
peu les débats et les filles hier soir à
retirer plus d'un millier d'amendements
et les socialistes ont dit avoir retiré
90% des leurres pour arriver à cet
article à cet article
non non ça c'était avant là j'ai pas
j'ai pas fait le comptage je ne sais pas
combien
de recettes il faut voter les articles
sur les recettes avant d'arriver à la
partie sur les dépenses donc le but là
des oppositions et d'arriver à cet
article 7 pour montrer qu'il y a une
hostilité à votre négativité il voudrait
avoir un vote négatif pour pour ancrer
leur discours alors
est-ce donc la principale mesure donc
l'article 7 qu'est-ce qui a été concédé
jusqu'à présent par le gouvernement
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de choses et
d'ailleurs c'est un peu le problème
parce que cette réforme elle est quand
même faite pour faire des économies
c'est une réforme paramétrique on est là
pour remettre d'équerre les comptes et
combler le déficit des retraites qui
sera de 13,5 milliards d'euros
en 2000 pardon en 2030 donc l'objectif
de la réforme avec la mesure d'âge et
l'accélération de la durée de cotisation
c'était d'arriver à 17 à dégager 17,7
milliards d'euros d'économies en 2030
alors 17,7 milliards d'euros d'économie
13,5 milliards de déficits vous me dites
il y a un petit peu de marge
effectivement il y avait
un peu plus de 4,8 milliards de marge
pour financer des mesures sociales donc
ça ça avait été annoncé dès le départ
Elisabeth borne avait annoncé par
exemple que toutes les personnes en
invalidité inaptitude pourraient
continuer à partir à 62 ans ça coûte
plus de 3 milliards ils avaient annoncé
aussi la revalorisation des minimas de
pension pour les nouveaux retraités ça
coûte un peu moins d'un milliard 700
millions d'euros mais à chaque passage
la facture celle où on dit parce que le
gouvernement lâche différentes mesures
il y a eu d'abord le passage en conseil
des ministres et là ils ont ajouté ils
ont dit banco pour la revalorisation des
petites retraites traitent non seulement
pour les nouveaux traités mais pour le
stock pour tous les anciens traités et
là ça coûte 1 milliard plus d'un
milliard supplémentaire donc on arrive
déjà à une facture de 5,9 milliards puis
ensuite la première ministre a annoncé
une mesure pour les 21 ans qui n'étaient
pas concernés par les carrières longues
qui auraient pu de voir travailler
jusqu'à 44 ans de avoir 44 ans de
cotisations donc là elle a dit ok sous
la pression d'Aurélien Pradier on ne
frappe pas plus de 43 ans parce que
c'est pas tous les lers au Sénat ils ne
sont pas
ça c'est une mesure encore à un milliard
en vitesse de croisière ça coûte 600
millions au départ quand ça monte en
charge mais en vitesse de croisière ça
coûte à nouveau un milliard d'euros par
an ensuite
hier Elisabeth borne à nouveau dit
qu'elle que cette cette ce dispositif
des 43 ans serait bien appliquée aux
gens qui sont en carrière longue donc
qui peuvent déjà partir plus tôt et
voilà elle a cédé aussi alors que
elle avait jusqu'à présent dit qu'elle
ne sonnerait pas et là c'est encore une
mesure coûteuse donc si vous voulez au
fur et à mesure c'est plus 30% on avait
Bruno le meilleur avait dit bon les
mesures d'accompagnement c'est un tiers
des économies de la réforme mais plus
plus on avance et on est plus proche des
50% que des que des 30 % donc du coup
donc je note c'était juste j'oublie le
premier renoncement
ça a été
qui avait été annoncé pourtant pendant
la campagne présidentielle et sur
laquelle Emmanuel Macron a été élu et le
premier renoncement ça a été dit on fait
pas 65 mai 64 qui est une mesure
beaucoup moins puissante financièrement
et qui a moins de qui a moins d'effets
dans la durée donc on sait déjà que de
toute façon après 2030 il faudra refaire
une nouvelle réforme il faudra y revenir
parce que le déficit des retraites il se
il se creuse encore plus à ce moment-là
et que la mesure 64 ans elle elle son
effet ce ce réduira alors pour l'instant
donc passer à la mesure de 64 ans
permettait de dégager donc 17 17 un peu
plus de 17 milliards d'euros et ce qui
permet d'être comblé un déficit de 13,5
milliards si vous voyez bien si je vous
ai bien compris est-ce que avec toutes
les concessions qui ont été faites avec
toutes les gestes qui ont été faits par
le gouvernement est-ce qu'on va encore
arriver à ce chiffre de 17 milliards
d'euros question subsidiaire est-ce
qu'on va arriver même aux chiffres de 13
milliards d'euros qui permet de combler
le déficit parce que quand je j'ai fait
toute l'addition là vous voyez la
facture s'allonge et donc
là c'est sûr que on est à moins de 13,5
alors le gouvernement est assez flou sur
les dernières
mesures dans la rue peut-être moins
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs on est en train
de le voir on va justement tenir la
comptabilité tout au long de
l'après-midi mais en fait ne va pas
permettre de combler le déficit
qu'elle avait prévu de combat au fur et
à mesure des annonces alors
et ça va quand même un rapporter les euh
ça va rapporter
si on distribue au fur et à mesure si on
distribue au fur et à mesure alors le
gouvernement n'a pas chiffré toutes les
mesures notamment celle qui a été
annoncée hier sur les sur les cas
carrière longue qui n'auraient que 43
ans de l'année de cotisation
et il vous disent quand vous leur posez
la question il vous disent oh mais on va
on va trouver des moyens de financer
alors vous dites bon mais comment alors
il vous parle de des c'est un peu
technique mais des du des de la
fiscalité sur les ruptures
conventionnelles donc ils vont ils vont
modifier ils vont ajuster les taux et ça
pourrait rapporter 200 à 250 millions
d'euros mais voyez
50% bon bref ils vont changer les taux
pour les entreprises donc le but premier
c'est que les entreprises sont incitées
à garder leur seniors dans l'entreprise
mais du coup elles ont voilà elles
perdront davantage si elle se sépare de
leur seniors trop tôt avec des ruptures
conventionnelles mais ça rapporte 200 à
250 millions c'est pas à la hauteur du
tout des concessions qui ont été faites
donc quand vous leur soulignez ça ils
vous disent mais le débat n'est pas
terminé nous allons trouver pendant le
débat les moyens de financer mais vous
voyez bien que les députés ils sont plus
pompe à faire des dépenses et à trouver
des nouvelles recettes donc je le
gouvernement dit nous notre objectif
c'est de maintenir l'équilibre de la
réforme de voilà de c'est quand même le
but la réforme elle est faite pour
dégager des économies combler le déficit
je vous rappelle que la France a 3000
milliards d'euros de dettes qu'on est
vis-à-vis on est depuis des années on
promet à Bruxelles à nos partenaires
européens que on va faire des réformes
et voilà si la montagne accouche d'une
souris ça met tout le monde dans la rue
ça ne ça ne rassure pas les marchés
financiers ça va surprennent nos
partenaires européens et les efforts de
tous
pourraient être gagé pour faire des
concessions à quelques-uns ce que vous
êtes en train de me dire quand même dans
le contenu c'est que c'est une affaire
ou personne mécontente
déjà d'emblée personne ne voulait
personne de détecteur ne veut faire
personne n'est content sur le sur le
plan c'est-à-dire que si en tous les cas
c'était une réforme qui permettait de
dégager 17 milliards d'euros qui
permettait à la fois de combler le
déficit et puis de garder une marge
financière pour les déficits de futurs
si vous comprenez dans tous les cas
c'était ce qui était dans les tuyaux
dans les dernières semaines parce que
avant c'était pour financer d'autres
mesures c'était au mois de septembre
mais la juge qu'ils ont pas été clair
sur l'explication je répète les
cotisations au retraites enfin les
années supplémentaires de travail les
cotisations retraite iront bien au
déficit des retraites quand ils disent
c'est pour financer l'hôpital l'École
etc c'est parce que quand on travaille
plus longtemps il y a forcément vous
gagnez davantage donc vous payez vous
consommez davantage vous payez plus de
TVA vous payez plus d'impôts et c'est
ces recettes autres que les cotisations
retraite pure qui iront financé l'école
la dépendance l'hôpital la santé mais
les cotisations retraite elles vont au
système de retraite et elles vont
normalement combler le déficit
mais effectivement comme je vous le
dites les
partisans de la réforme parce qu'il y en
a quand même qui sont résignés qui
savaient bien que nécessité féloi
même ceux qui défendent la réforme
finissent par se dire il faut quand même
pas aller trop loin dans les concessions
sinon mais c'est toujours Raymond souby
conseiller social de Nicolas Sarkozy le
répète souvent dans toutes les réformes
le principal enjeu c'est que la réforme
qui est faite pour faire des économies
ne devienne pas plus coûteuses que que
son objectif question est-ce que c'est
pas ce qui est en train pourtant de se
passer
on est quand même pas on y est pas mais
ça coûte de plus en plus cher je vous
dis on est à une approche plus
maintenant des 50% que des 30%. il y a
une bonne ambiance dans les
manifestations c'est en tout cas ce que
nous disent les journalistes qui sont
déployés sur place les journalistes du
Figaro qui sont à la fois à Albi et à
Paris vous pouvez suivre également
d'ailleurs toutes les informations
complémentaires à ces images à ces
explications à ses éclairages qu'on est
en train de vous donner sur le live
texte du Figaro qui est juste en dessous
de ce player
oui c'est intéressant donc la les
leaders syndicaux sont à Albi bon
première raison pour pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils sont allés dans une petite ville
d'abord parce que c'est les vacances
scolaires parce que c'est la question
d'ailleurs
que je vous ai que je voulais vous poser
mais quel intérêt on les syndicats
aujourd'hui à maintenir cette
mobilisation il y a beaucoup la question
autour de ça alors que les deux tiers du
pays sont en vacances scolaire il faut
maintenir la pression le texte il est à
l'Assemblée donc il faut maintenir la
pression avant la pose voilà donc
maintenir la pression et donc pourquoi
lui parce que en Occitanie ils ne sont
pas en vacances deuxièmement c'était
habile de leur part de mettre le focus
le projecteur sur ces petites villes de
province qui ont qui sont beaucoup
mobilisés et ça ça embarrasse le
gouvernement parce que ce sont souvent
dans autant à Paris et dans les grandes
villes dans les cortèges on retrouve
beaucoup de militants syndicaux les
syndicats à fêter des cas il y a
beaucoup de militants dans les cortèges
autant dans ces ces petites villes de
province on retrouve des gens des
classes moyennes des gens qui ne souvent
me manifestent pour la première fois qui
n'ont pas l'habitude et ça ça ennuie le
gouvernement donc
parce que ça refait penser un peu au
temps c'est logique que les militants
syndicaux manifestent autant que des
gens se lèvent ça montre quand même que
le projet est contesté et ça rappelle ça
fait craindre une gilet jauneisation de
de la contestation donc voyez ça c'était
c'était habile de leur part
pas très très grand vous parliez et
pendant que on traite d'image avec des
images à Paris il m'a envoyé également
des gilets jaunes ici à Albi
Tarbes ou Albi et puis bon finalement
c'est Albi qu'il a
remportérelle entre localement entre les
syndicats il fallait que ce soit c'était
voilà une région aussi où il y avait des
des rassemblements assez nombreux et qui
n'étaient pas en vacances je on va
justement regarder encore ces images
mais avant de vous laisser Marie-Cécile
une dernière question à l'heure où à
l'heure qu'il est si la réforme était
adoptée définitivement aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui changerait qu'est-ce qui
continuerait pour nos retraites
pas le principal si c'est adopté le
principal changement c'est que
progressivement
l'âge l'âge légal va augmenter et que la
durée de cotisation l'augmentation de la
durée de cotisation qui était déjà
enclenchée avec la réforme Touraine les
gens n'en n'ont pas forcément conscience
mais c'était déjà beauté là elle va être
accélérée donc progressivement il va
falloir travailler plus de trimestres et
à partir de
de 2030 il faudra donc aller jusqu'à 75
ans
merci beaucoup à tous les internautes
qui nous rejoignent je salue notamment
lansarter qui est là depuis vraiment
surnommé même lance starter parce qu'il
était là depuis le début depuis le début
du live également mensana Christian Léon
qui nous rejoint bonjour Christian Léon
et vous continuez à commenter à poser
d'autres questions merci de rester dans
le cadre des chartes de modération je
sais que ces réformes font réagir ces
manifestations vont mais on reste dans
sa cadre courtois et
démocratique
une petite question
je posais la question est-ce qu'on sait
combien il y a d'articles dans cette loi
parce qu'on parle toujours de l'article
2 ou de l'article 7 et donc après
l'article 7 c'est quoi les autres
artistes oh ben il y a plein de mesures
très techniques là je prenais de cours
qu'est-ce qu'il y a des mesures sur la
pénibilité bon il y avait la mesure où
il y avait
le Seigneur l'index seniors qui a été
rejeté mais que le gouvernement espère
bien remettre au Sénat
qui était à votre place samedi dernier
le patron de la CFTC nous dit mais c'est
juste un
index indicatif la seule contrainte
c'est de dire de publier un index ce
qu'on veut nous par exemple syndicat
c'est que il est plus de il y a une
contrainte pour employer des seniors
l'argument des syndicats les syndicats
dit c'est une coquille vide parce que
l'oblige cette index c'est quoi c'est
uniquement les entreprises de plus de 50
salariés doivent dire quelle est leur
pour de seniors elles doivent le publier
sur leur site internet tiennent publie
pas elles auraient une amende une amende
égale à 1% de leur masse salariale donc
c'est quand même pas rien mais c'est
juste de la publication il y a pas de
quota et non pas d'obligation à employer
des seniors donc les syndicats disent ce
sera rien c'est une coquille vide en
fait c'est une technique un dispositif
de une pratique de Naiman shame vous
voyez on veut on le gouvernement pense
que avec la pub enfin pense distinguer
les bons élèves des mauvais et que si on
pointe des pratiques les pratiques des
mauvais élèves ça va les inciter à être
meilleur apparemment il y a comme les
syndicats qui sont le patronat aussi
trouve cette mesure incohérente
à cette mesure pour être justement
raccord avec le patronaté parce que au
départ de la mesure devait s'appliquer
au plus de 300 salariés au plus grosses
entreprises finalement le gouvernement
l'a encore à cédé et à abaisser le seuil
à au plus de 50 donc elle est reprend la
défense des petites entreprises pour qui
se serait compliqué non le patronat il
est il est il est il pointe des
incohérences parce qu'il dit mais une
entreprise qui a des seniors qui les
gardent mais qui mais bon élève et
embauche aussi des jeunes embauche des
apprentis par exemple et bien
mécaniquement son taux de seniors va
baisser mécaniquement si elle embauche
des jeunes tout en gardant ses seniors
et bien elle sera moins bien notée
qu'une entreprise qui n'embauche pas de
jeunes vous voyez c'est un peu
incohérent enfin le
patronatic ça n'a pas de sens de
comparer entre elles des entreprises en
plus avec des secteurs très différents
ou vous allez pas comparer une start-up
où il y a plein de jeunes et puis
d'autres entreprises avec un historique
vous voyez donc eux disent ça n'a pas de
sens et puis c'est encore bureaucratisé
administré l'économie enfin c'est
soviétiser l'économie
encore plus de la de la bureaucratie et
de la et de la soviététisation Merci
beaucoup Marie-Cécile qu'est-ce que vous
allez guetter dans les aujourd'hui dans
les manifestations et dans les heures
qui viennent
là c'est assez
tranquille ça s'essouffle il y a pas il
y a pas autant de monde que dans les
précédentes
dans les précédentes manifestations donc
là en fait il y a une sorte de ventre
mou qui va se passer pendant les
vacances non ce qui va être intéressant
à suivre c'est début mars parce que là
là il va y avoir un durcissement vous
l'avez entendu tout à l'heure je crois
que c'est Fabien Roussel qui disait on
se mobilise dès le 7 mars ensuite le 8
mars et la journée des femmes donc là
aussi mobilisation prévue le 9 les
organisations de jeunesse s'appellent
les jeunes à descendre dans la rue pour
l'instant ça n'a pas pris la jeunesse
même si sporadiquement il y a quelques
quelques lycées
le fil data aujourd'hui c'est quand même
début mars que il va y avoir un
durcissement là on est un peu dans le
ventre mou du mouvement l'image de
l'interse syndical alors là c'est un
petit peu caché par les photographes et
les
personnes qui sont devant la banderole
des syndicats à Albi mais on va on va
retrouver cette image d'un instant
talent vous voyez également des images
de paris en direct alors celle là on
voit des mobilisations les plus fortes
en tous les cas plus compactes que sur
d'autres images on voyait une
mobilisation plus espacées notamment
place de la Bastille pointe de départ de
la manifestation alors on va vous le
savez
le premier pour la première mobilisation
ou vous souvenez le cortège avait eu
beaucoup de mal à démarrer parce que les
gens piétinaient il y avait tellement de
monde que ça n'avançait pas là on voit
que c'est on a vu au fil des des
mouvements que c'était quand même plus
plus espacés et que le cortège était
plus rapide assez lancé en tous les cas
c'est les informations également qui
nous remontent de nos de nos
journalistes qui sont déployés au sein
de ces manifestations
notamment à Lyon ou le correspondant
nous dit que le nombre de manifestations
de manifestants sont moins élevés que
samedi et
au niveau voire un peu moins du cortège
du 7 février c'est à dire mardi dernier
qui était déjà un cortège en baisse
merci beaucoup Marie-Cécile et ben on va
regarder ces images on va les mettre en
plein pot pour vous les laisser vivre et
voir avec faire le point également de la
mobilisation dans les secteurs des
transports avec
François de lettrase merci beaucoup et
merci de d'avoir commenté ces premières
infos avec nous merci beaucoup
Marie-Cécile
[Musique]
voilà Figaro live
14h47 merci beaucoup d'être toujours
avec nous à la fois sur le site du
Figaro et également sur la page Youtube
du Figaro extrêmement bien animé par
l'équipe des réseaux sociaux et en
particulier Adrien brillant une solution
manif sur Manise manif nous dit anabi
sur manif pour que Macron dégage par
référendum on en est sans doute pas
encore là
déjà avec le rejet de l'article 2 Macron
veut le remettre en lecture au Sénat et
ça c'est vrai c'est ce que nous disait
tout à l'heure Marie Cécile en tous les
cas le gouvernement bonjour François de
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
vous suivez
la question particulière des transports
pour le pour Le Figaro vous êtes un
spécialiste on pourrait dire un
transportologue si le terme a
transporteur
[Musique]
précisément justement dans le secteur
des transports train métro
RER bus quelle a été l'ampleur des
blocages aujourd'hui
j'ai pu venir enfin en train de ma
banlieue lointaine à Paris aujourd'hui
comme disent les Québécois c'est pas si
pire
ce qui veut dire ce n'est pas trop
mauvais le premier indice c'est
évidemment l'indice des bouchons si on
regarde l'indice des bouchons
d'aujourd'hui on a eu un petit pic à
8h30 du matin mais qui n'a pas atteint
le maximum des bouchons qu'on avait
d'habitude et là depuis
19h30 on est exactement dans la moyenne
habituelle donc ça veut dire qu'il y a
pas les gens ne se sont pas ruées sur
leur voiture pour venir travailler
ça veut dire donc les transports
fonctionnaient plutôt bien ou qu'ils
étaient en télétravail mais la réalité
c'est que les transports aussi bien à
Paris qu'en région dans les métropoles
fonctionnent bien il y a un problème un
peu particulier pour les terres en
région qui fonctionnent qu'ils ont très
perturbé alors justement c'est là où
c'était une des questions que je vais
vous poser où justement ça le plus
bloqué alors en général
j'ai fait un tour de France en gros on a
intra sur deux quasiment sur toute la
France dans toutes les régions de France
donc c'est un c'est un lourd impact
à parler bon la plupart des lignes sont
gérées par la SNCF mais on a quand même
intra sur deux ce qui est peu et c'est
d'autant plus surprenant que dans les
métropoles par exemple Toulouse
Marseille Lyon on y viendra le résultat
sont plutôt bons c'est-à-dire qu'on est
un trafic proche de la normale qui va
par exemple se dégrader à Marseille sur
la ligne 2 là en ce moment c'est normal
mais en fin de journée on va tomber à un
train toutes les 7 minutes 30 ce qui est
peu donc voyez on a des fluctuations en
fluide de journée dans les dans les
régions qui sont un peu surprenantes
à Toulouse les tramas et de sont assez
impactés parce qu'il y a quand même un
seul tram toutes les 15 minutes
le reste est à peu près normal
à Lyon il faut savoir qu'il y a comme
dans d'autres villes il y a des
interruptions de trafic mais qui sont
pas dues à la grève
à Lyon par exemple le métro numéro 2 ne
marche pas du tout aujourd'hui
même chose en région parisienne le
Orlyval pour aller à orlyne fonctionne
pas parce qu'il est en travaux sur Paris
tout ce qui est métro fonctionne à peu
près normalement il faut savoir qu'à
cause de la manifestation il y a 25
lignes de bus qui sont impactées ou sur
toute le parcours ou sur une partie du
parcours et l'autre gros souci c'est le
RER B ou sur la branche nord c'est à
dire gare du Nord vers mitry-clay ou
l'aéroport Charles de Gaulle il y a
quatre un sur deux et sur la partie sud
il y a deux trains sur trois sachant que
une fois de plus l'interconnexion à la
gare du Nord est interrompu et que si
vous devez aller du Châtelet à Roissy il
faut que vous changiez de train à la
gare du Nord
quel est l'ampleur là on voit donc des
images à l'huile bon c'est un peu
clairsemé Albi c'était 6000 manifestants
samedi dernier pour une ville de 5000
habitants donc c'était pas 6000
forcément Albigeois qui qui manifestait
mais en tous les cas 6000 personnes qui
sont réunies dans les rues de la
préfecture du Tarn où on a vu partir
tout à l'heure donc les leaders
syndicaux en particulier côte à côte
Philippe Martinez et de la CGT et
Laurent Berger de la CFDT ainsi que s'il
y a une Chabanier de la CFTC
quel est l'ampleur de la mobilisation
justement chez les salariés
et les employés du secteur des
transports et en particulier du
transport public alors elle est en forte
baisse
je pense pour des raisons financières
parce que vous savez que la caisse de la
caisse de grève comme on l'appelle
ne compte qu'une partie du salaire le
jour de grève et donc les gens au bout
de un jour deux jours trois jours on
commence à commence à le sentir et
là on voit les effets d'une vraie baisse
de du taux de grévistes dans les
différents moyens de transport sauf sur
les TER où il y a curieusement en région
il y a encore pas mal de grévistes
c'est donc aujourd'hui principalement en
région où il y a la plus forte
mobilisation en grande ligne on a peu de
mobilisation
l'Eurostar est normal le tarélie c'est
normal
le TGV Nord et normale le tgvs est
normal l'Atlantique est normal il y a
uniquement le
Sud-Est où il y a deux trains sur trois
mais c'est quand même beaucoup de trains
et ouigo de 1 sur 3 aussi contre quoi
exactement finalement les cheminots les
traminots les personnels de transport se
mobilisent pour l'instant il par rapport
en tous les cas aux mesures dont il
bénéficient ils ne sont pas concernés
autrement que par le report de l'âge de
départ là il y a deux catégories de
personnels chez les cheminots il y a
ceux qui ont droit à la retraite du
régime spécial et ceux qui n'ont pas
droit tous les nouveaux entrants n'ont
pas droit au régime spécial et ce qu'on
appelle le statut et donc en fait il y a
il y a une différence très nette de
mobilisation chez les uns chez les
autres sachant que ceux qui sont là
depuis toujours auront droit à une belle
retraite alors que ceux qui arrivent
auront droit et la retraite du secteur
public comme depuis plus où il parle
d'une certaine publique comme tout le
monde Dominique nous dit comment
détourner notre attention sur la
retraite alors qu'il y a également
l'inflation l'énergie les pompiers et
infirmières et notamment les infirmières
suspendues c'est intéressant ce que vous
dites parce que c'est un point sur
lequel on va revenir tout à l'heure
notamment avec Marie visault qui est
rédactrice en chef au service économie
au Figaro économie et on va revenir
justement sur les sur les autres
dimensions en tous les cas et également
avec l'Arthur by Jota sur les autres
en tous les cas les autres motifs de
manifester notamment en région
grève surprise à Orly samedi dernier
François est-ce qu'il faut craindre la
même chose samedi prochain alors les
contrôleurs aériens
qui étaient en grève qui était en grève
pose des prêts de grève très
régulièrement mais ne les effectue pas
mais ils font ça c'est un peu l'inverse
c'est l'inverse
50% des des c'est comme une partie des
passagers qui se sont retrouvés en rade
mais c'est comme c'est le même phénomène
que les contrôleurs en décembre dernier
à savoir que les centrales syndicales
déposent des durées de grève et puis
tout d'un coup il y a une catégorie de
personnels qui décide de faire grève
donc ça c'est c'est toute la
problématique
d'une décision de dernière minute
sachant qu'à Orly il y a un deuxième
problème qui se pose c'est que la DGAC
la direction générale à l'avion Sicile a
mal calculé le nombre de contrôleurs de
ciel dont elle aura besoin et elle
contraint les compagnies aériennes à
réduire le nombre d'avions le matin
parce qu'elle a pas assez de contrôleur
donc ça ça n'a rien à voir avec la grève
est-ce que dans les autres transports il
faut s'attendre on peut craindre un
mouvement comparable à celui qu'on a
connu à Orly Samedi dernier vous parliez
tout à l'heure de la grève inopinée des
contrôleurs SNCF à Noël est-ce que ça
peut arriver encore dans les jours à
venir qui vont correspondre au départ en
vacances scolaires de la zone A qui
c'est-à-dire la zone vous Paris et aussi
vous pensez à qui je pense que contrôler
la SNCF par exemple et ça ils ont obtenu
ce qu'il voulait il y a pas il y a pas
de raison qui s'y remettent les
contrôles les contrôleurs aériens c'est
plus compliqué parce qu'on est on est
dans une phase de transformation très
importante de leur métier avec une
Européenne qui est nécessaire des routes
aériennes pour économiser du kérosène
donc forcément il y a un jour où les
contrôleurs aériens seront sous une
autorité européenne et plus sous une
autorité française
mais auprès de
des pétroliers des DDF etc etc et puis
la deuxième crainte du gouvernement
toujours dans avec les transports c'est
que les gens fassent grève par
substitution c'est-à-dire que le
français moyen qui trouve que son pour
pouvoir d'achat baisse va être très
content que la SNCF est les syndicats de
la SNCF fassent grève pour lui donc ça
c'est tout le danger de ces grèves avec
les transports images vous le voyez
encore Albi dans le Tarn ou c'était
lancé donc la manifestation avec les 8
leaders syndicaux à leur tête c'est
information à retrouver sur notre live
texte également qui est en dessous de ce
player sur le site du Figaro et bien sûr
vous continuez de nous suivre sur
Youtube on va prendre quelques-unes de
vos questions d'ailleurs
leur ras-le-bol dans les manifs est plus
que général nous dit PAO il ne faut pas
oublier que le prochain chantier la
sécurité sociale on entend également des
des
propos en tout cas des slogans
des motifs de manifestation autour de la
question de l'inflation on y reviendra
peut-être tout à l'heure est-ce qu'on
peut se faire rembourser les jours de
grève quand on est usagé des transports
et que on a subi des suppressions de
train quand on a subi
des mesures commerciales
la grève étant un droit constitutionnel
les entreprises sont pas obligées de
rembourser en revanche ce qu'elles font
la plupart du temps c'est qu'elles
permettent aux gens de transférer leurs
voyages à une date de leur choix sans
pénalité on voit une grande mobilisation
dans les villes moyennes et les petites
villes est-ce qu'il y a des blocages de
transport dans cette ville alors prenons
l'exemple d'Albi Albi c'est une ville
qui a un réseau d'autobus on va dire
petit comparé à Toulouse à Lyon à
Marseille etc etc et en général ce sont
des des réseaux qui sont
donner en délégation de service public à
des entreprises privées ça peut être
carte postale ça peut être Transdev ça
peut être Keolis donc on a un phénomène
de grève qui est qui est peu pas évident
dans les toutes petites villes et toute
façon le moyen de transport le plus
important dans les villes moyennes c'est
la voiture le transport public compte
pour quasiment rien l'image à lui on va
peut-être regarder dans un instant les
images de la Bastille également à Paris
où se réunissait la tête de
manifestation voilà merci beaucoup à
notre magicien c'est-à-dire notre
réalisateur Riad Becker d'avoir fait ce
qu'on appelle dans notre jargon le
switch et on voit que c'est un petit peu
plus clairsemé en tous les cas sur la
partie qui est précisément devant la
Banque de France à Place de la Bastille
à Paris avec donc un départ vers la
Place d'Italie on verra justement si
c'est un effet d'optique ou si ça
correspond à une réalité les chauffeurs
de bus loués par un syndicat
d'entreprise ne peut pas non plus avoir
une place gratuite pour une pour un
musée il se la garde pour lui il y a des
c'est ce que nous dit Christian il y a
des privilèges de bus pas que je sache
il y a il y avait un certain nombre de
privilèges de biais gratuit qui était
dans les contrats aussi bien chez Air
France que en fait dans toutes les
compagnies aériennes c'est l'usage donc
de là à croire qu'ils ont des billets
gratuits pour aller au musée je suis pas
sûr merci beaucoup de cette précision
mon cher François de détresse merci
beaucoup votre fidélité pour venir
toujours éclairer et répondre aux
internautes du Figaro il y a plus de
ballons que de genre nous dit Charles
alors ça c'est la foire du Trône c'est
pas si c'est exactement vrai mais en
tous les cas effectivement on voit bien
que il y a une visibilité une tentative
de rendre visible chacun des syndicats
qui on le disait tout à l'heure avec
Marie-Cécile Renaud
font le plein en tout cas au niveau des
adhésions en ce moment et profitent de
cette mobilisation vous êtes au bord
d'une manifestation et qu'il y a plein
de ballons plein de drapeaux etc c'est
toujours impressionnant c'est comme un
spectacle donc il faut montrer que ça
puisse aussi par ses moyens là voilà
donc c'est en tout cas ce qui se passe
place de la Bastille en ce moment à
Paris pendant que on le voit également
le cortège continue d'avancer à Albi
François-Xavier bourreau du service
politique va venir nous rejoindre dans
un instant en attendant justement je
vous propose de regarder ce qui se passe
à Albi de regarder vivre cette
manifestation et on se retrouve juste
après
[Musique]
15h04 merci beaucoup d'être toujours
avec nous sur YouTube sur le site du
Figaro et merci à François-Xavier
bourneau de nous rejoindre sur dans les
studios du Figaro François-Xavier qui
est un spécialiste
notamment de la majorité et qui a suivi
plusieurs campagnes d'Emmanuel Macron
qui a dès le départ en tout cas à ses
chances et c'était à l'époque
c'était pas évident et vous avez des
biens raconté les coulisses de ces
victoires de ses accessoires au pouvoir
et puis également de ce tango des
fossoyeurs que forme la majorité
actuelle avec le rassemblement national
et
Marine Le Pen où en est-on justement à
l'Assemblée actuellement alors ils vont
bien ils sont toujours en train de
discuter là sur le je crois qu'il leur
reste 4000 amendements à examiner avant
d'arriver à l'article à l'article 7
alors vous faites bien de me le dire
parce qu'on savait plus on était tout à
l'heure avec
Cécile Renaud donc effectivement il y
avait 11000 amendements au départ et
puis il y a eu quand même des retraits
successives donc pour l'instant d'après
ce que voilà il reste donc la la la
partie
le premier parti du texte à examiner ils
peuvent pas les députés ne peuvent pas
aller directement à l'examen de
l'article 7 parce qu'il s'agit d'un
projet de loi de finances qui sont
obligés d'examiner le volet recette
avant d'examiner le volet de dépenses et
donc là avant d'arriver au cœur du sujet
quoi l'article 7 il reste 4000
amendements enfin il en reste 4000 à 13h
tout à l'heure ce que vous me dites
c'est que entre l'article 2 qui a été
rejeté en début de semaine et l'article
7 qui devrait pourrait être discuté
d'ici la fin de l'Espagne et qui doit en
tout cas l'être il y a un certain nombre
d'amendements cinq amendements qui
concerne les les recettes gouvernement
en réalité le seul enjeu qui qui a
l'Assemblée nationale c'est de savoir
s'il est députés arrivent à examiner cet
article 7 parce que c'est celui qui
porte sur le report de l'âge légal de
départ en retraite et c'est celui sur
lequel se cristallise toutes les tous
les tous les débats et contre lequel se
mobilisent les manifestants depuis fin
janvier quel est l'état d'esprit du
gouvernement à l'heure où on se parle
alors ils sont assez confiants sur le
vote malgré les rebondissements qu'il y
a eu il pense pouvoir obtenir l'appui et
le soutien de LR pour voter la réforme
des retraites et donc le obtenir une
majorité à l'Assemblée pour ce pour ce
texte malgré tout le coût de Trafalgar
sur le sur l'article 2 c'est un petit
peu alerté parce que il manquait dans
l'hémicycle 50 députés renaissance de la
majorité un peu de un peu de
démobilisation et quand et puis quand
bien même ces députés auraient été
présents dans l'hémicycle et aurait voté
pour en faveur de l'article 2 ils
auraient quand même perdu parce que donc
il y a cet allié qui est un petit peu un
petit peu instable sur lequel il compte
s'appuyer pour faire adopter la réforme
donc ils savent pas trop si vous réussir
à tenir les les troupes jusqu'au bout
alors
d'après des échanges qui ont eu lieu à
l'Assemblée nationale en coulisses entre
eriki les représentants de la majorité
eriki a expliqué Renaissance qu'il avait
besoin de de relâcher un peu la pression
de ne faire redescendre un peu le débat
pour calmer un peu ces troupes d'où le
vote contre l'article 2 est-ce que tout
ça va va tenir jusqu'au bout c'est à ce
que Éric Ciotti aura réussi à faire
descendre la pression et calmer un peu
ses troupes pour qu'ils acceptent de
voter en masse
la réforme des retraites
c'est encore un certain hémicide qui est
chauffé à blanc comme ça en ce moment
c'est un petit peu compliqué alors vous
le passe une nous dit les LR n'ont pas
pris de risque avec l'article 2 c'est
pour éviter les papiers qui font crouler
les entreprises donc la paperasse qui
ferait couler les entreprises qui nous
expliquaient tout à l'heure en tous les
cas le mari Cécile Renaud et
le vol pas eu il lui dit également c'est
pas forcément une victoire pour
Mélenchon mais c'était c'était un totem
visiblement pour une partie de LR oui
oui parce qu'il faut pas oublier que LR
est aussi proche du Medef que le Medef
était très opposé à cette index seniors
donc c'est une façon de satisfaire les
les députés proches du Medef vraiment de
faire redescendre la pression au sein de
LR qui est vraiment tiraillé en ce
moment avec cette cette réforme c'est
tout le paradoxe qui est en deçà de ce
qu'il défendait au Sénat durant ces 10
dernières années viennent amendement qui
était régulièrement présenté par Bruno
Retailleau pour un report de l'âge légal
de départ en retraite à 65 ans là ils
sont un petit peu en porte-à-faux parce
que c'est LR qui obtient toutes les
concessions et qui détricote une réforme
qu'ils auraient vraisemblablement faites
plus dur s'ils avaient été au pouvoir
donc il y a cette espèce de jeu affront
renversé qui se déroule à l'Assemblée
nationale à un moment va bien falloir
rétablir retrouver son assiette c'est à
dire défendre une des formes une réforme
que LR a toujours défendu voté pour une
informe que l'air a toujours défendu
ira-t-on jusqu'à l'article 7 alors c'est
l'enjeu
il y a plusieurs choses parce que tout
le monde n'a pas intérêt à aller jusqu'à
l'article 7
ma question subsidiaire justement c'est
est-ce que le gouvernement veut vraiment
un vote de l'article 16 bah oui oui ce
serait une victoire pour eux de montrer
que dans l'hémicycle ils ont une
majorité pour soutenir cette réforme ce
serait le contrepoint à la rue c'est à
dire il y a pas d'inquiétude qui est lié
justement à ce qui s'est passé sur
l'article 2 non
on aura quand même quelques chiffres
dans les dans les heures à venir et le
cortège notamment qui vient de passer
devant le Jardin des Plantes nous disent
Vladimir garçon qui a des journées sur
place et qui ici c'est toujours dans le
calme et ça contraste ça contraste avec
l'ambiance à l'Assemblée toujours oui
alors c'est c'est
il y a moins de victimes mais ça c'est
ça c'est pas calmé la pie ça va ça va
les camps d'empiron plus on va
rapprocher de l'échéance parce qu'il y a
le coup près à minuit vendredi soir les
débats s'arrêtent alors est-ce qu'on
peut justement on l'a déjà beaucoup
expliqué mais peut-être le réexpliquer
en tout cas à nos internautes pourquoi
la discussion doit s'arrêter en tout cas
en première lecture absolument vendredi
soir alors c'est cette technique
j'espère que je vais pas vous faire
perdre des internautes allez on va voir
c'est le défi aux internautes soit vous
allez tenir à l'explication de
François-Xavier mais il est tellement
didactique il est tellement pédagogue
avec beaucoup de Tal que à mon avis je
prépare vous allez rester et votre
lanterne va être éclairée je vais
essayer de le faire simple pour faire
passer la réforme des retraites Emmanuel
Macron a choisi aller un véhicule
législatif particulier c'est le projet
de loi de finance rectificatif pour pour
aller vite c'est
qu'on a voté le budget au mois d'octobre
mais on rectifie un peu le budget qu'on
a qu'on a qu'on a voté au mois d'octobre
voilà c'est un texte qui a été voté le
budget et là on apporte quelques
changements dans ce dans ce texte là
c'est un véhicule législatif particulier
parce qu'il permet plusieurs choses la
première c'est de recourir aux 49.3
s'il le fallait pour faire passer la
réforme sans vote le quota de 49-3
non alors justement
on peut utiliser le les deux avantages
de ce véhicule législatif le premier
c'est que
le gouvernement peut utiliser le 49-3
sans griller ses cartouches c'est 49-3
illimité s'il le veut ça c'est le c'est
autorisé deuxième avantage il a utilisé
pour cette examiner cette loi l'article
49,7 qui lui si je lui je crois que
c'est un top 7 de j'ai un an
mais là vous me faites découvrir le 49
donc cette 47 bon enfin bref il y a un
article qui permet sur ces jeunes loi de
finance rectificative de faire un temps
de débat réduit il y a 20 jours de débat
ça permet de réduire la durée des débats
et donc la durée d'exposition médiatique
à la rue pendant l'examen de la réforme
de retraite 20 jours ça se termine
vendredi ensuite le texte par au Sénat
il est voté ou pas ou pas ou pas voter
au Sénat si le sénateur se mette pas
d'accord avec ce qui sort de l'Assemblée
nationale il est examiné par une
commission mixte paritaire qui rassemble
des sénateurs
de droite de gauche toutes les tendances
politiques du Sénat des députés de
toutes les tendances politiques de
l'Assemblée nationale il se réunissent
donc sur cette commission mixte
paritaire ils établissent un texte et ce
texte revient l'Assemblée nationale
c'est donc ce véhicule législatif il a
vraiment plusieurs avantages pour le
gouvernement il réduit le temps des
débats et il permet si ça devait
s'enliser d'utiliser le 49-3 pour le
dire vraiment très rapide c'est très
bien c'est beaucoup plus clair et on
comprend mieux en tous les cas ce qu'on
comprend ce que vous dites c'est que
le gouvernement fait tout pour aller
vite ce genre de ce genre d'affaires sur
quand même un dossier qui semble
important oui c'est le l'enjeu c'est
vraiment de passage en force c'est un
peu l'idée qui vient à l'esprit quand on
entend que vous explications alors il y
a quand même un peu de débat puisqu'il y
a 20 jours qui sont programmés à
l'Assemblée nationale mais ce débat se
déroule dans des conditions qui sont
délétères parce que la France insoumise
la nupesse on choisit une stratégie
d'obstruction qui vraisemblable
le premier pas encore mais qui pourrait
s'achever c'est débats par un texte qui
part au Sénat sans que l'article secte
ait été examiné voté par l'Assemblée
nationale là certains nous dit la
plupart de ces sénateurs ne sont pas
droites si actuellement
où trouver un marché le Président c'est
quand même Bruno Retailleau le président
du groupe LR voilà
oui c'est c'est compliqué tous ces
histoires de techniques parlementaires
mais c'est c'est un enjeu les maîtriser
et savoir utiliser tous les outils qui
sont à disposition des des députés c'est
un enjeu dans cette bataille qui se joue
aussi au Parlement parce que la réforme
des retraites en fait c'est un bataille
qui se joue sur deux fronts il y a le
front syndical avec des adversaires à
affronter pour le gouvernement ce qu'on
voit aujourd'hui là le gouvernement
affronte la rue et il y a le front
politique on va avoir d'ailleurs la rue
toute la France elle est à Albi on va la
voir dans un instant et avec le France
syndical donc le
la plupart des leaders de
France syndical qui est qui marche côte
à côte ici donc Albi en ce moment alors
pour l'instant il reviendra peut-être
après mais le Français syndical pour
l'instant est unique et il y a un
deuxième front qui est le front
politique ou là le gouvernement doit
trouver des alliés donc des adversaires
à affronter des alliés à trouver c'est
une bataille qui se mène sur deux francs
et donc qui est extrêmement compliqué je
parlais de l'unité syndicale l'enjeu
pour le gouvernement c'est de faire
voter la réforme des retraites parce que
on a bien identifié que Laurent Berger
était un leader syndical contre les le
report de l'âge légal de la retraite
mais il est aussi légitimiste à partir
du moment où l'Assemblée nationale la
représentation nationale adopte une loi
il y a plus de raison d'être dans la rue
et donc on espère que une fois que ce
texte sera voté et bien la CFDT sortira
mécaniquement du France syndical le
texte ayant été adopté par les
représentants du peuple il y a plus de
raison d'aller le contester dans la rue
c'est un pari du gouvernement
un peu risqué parce que Laurent Berger
peut décider de sortir respecter la vie
politique du pays les règles de la
démocratie mais ces troupes c'est moins
sûr vous parliez également d'un front
politique et Lancaster nous dit des LR
sont pris dans leur propre piège ah oui
oui non mais là tout le monde joue à
fond là j'étais avec une responsable de
renaissance il y a vraiment d'Emmanuel
Macron l'ex République en marche voilà
qui disait c'est assez fascinant ce qui
est en train de se passer on est en
train de se faire dépasser sur notre
gauche par la droite et c'est exactement
ça c'est que le les LR sont en train de
détricoter une réforme des retraites
qu'ils auraient vraisemblablement juré
jugé trop molle
s'ils avaient été dans l'opposition ils
y sont mais c'est en train d'obtenir
moins que ce qu'il demande il y a un
paradoxe dans cette dans cette histoire
mais
tout se mêle dans cette réforme des
retraites il y a des enjeux
culturels internes aux parties
Erik sotti doit asseoir sa légitimité de
président fraîchement élus au sein des
LR mais il y en a qui essaye de tirer
leur airpingle du jeu en jouant sur la
tactique du frondeur c'est quand vous
êtes minoritaire c'est minorité dans un
groupe qui peut faire basculer une
majorité c'est toujours très payant on a
plutôt tendance à briser le blocage
voilà minorité vous êtes un petit peu
l'empêcheur de tourner en rondes et on
voit d'ailleurs que c'est ce qu'a fait
Elisabeth borne elle a donné
satisfaction à Aurélien Pradier qui est
minoritaire au sein des LR LR qui sont
eux-mêmes seulement 3e groupe politique
à l'Assemblée nationale l'autre coup de
théâtre sur le front politique c'est
quand même le retour du RN dans la
course avec un dépôt de la motion de
censure alors ça c'est un coût politique
qui est très finement joué de la part de
Marine Le Pen c'est pas la première fois
qu'elle en fait un comme ça je rappelle
que pour le vote du budget elle avait
elle avait annoncé à la surprise
générale qu'elle allait voter la motion
de censure dé par la nupes contre le
budget de d'Élisabeth borne Marine Le
Pen et c'est très bien joué avec les
outils dont étaient disposés au
Parlement là il y avait cette cet outil
là disposition la motion censure elle en
a déposé une qu'est-ce que ça va
permettre alors
d'organiser un débat c'est-à-dire que
tous les chefs de groupe vont défiler à
la tribune pour expliquer pourquoi il
vote ou pas la motion de censure et donc
elle a coincé la nupaisse parce que la
nupesse n'ira jamais expliqué qui vont
voter une motion de censure déposée par
le RN elle a coincé LR parce que LR va
devoir aller expliquer à la tribune
pourquoi il ne vote pas la motion
censure déposée par le par le RN donc
pourquoi il soutiennent la réforme des
retraites ce qui au passage peut
augmenter les divisions à croître les
divisions qu'on voit au sein de LR et
puis vous allez avoir Marine Le Pen qui
va apparaître mécaniquement comme la
seule opposante crédible à la réforme
des retraites
donc c'est plutôt tout bénef pour Marine
Le Pen tout bénef aussi pour Elisabeth
borne parce que ça va structurer une
opposition entre d'un côté et la
majorité parlementaire de d'Emmanuel
Macron et le rassemblement national
retour du temps mais on y est on y est
c'est tous ces ce clivage qui structure
la vie politique depuis 2017 depuis la
première élection enfin depuis même le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle de 2017 comme Marine Le
Pen et Emmanuel Macron se retrouve face
à face alors tout à l'heure
Fabien Roussel le patron du PC disait
tout le mal qu'il pensait de cette
notion de censure déposée par Marine Le
Pen en disant que oui la cette notion de
censeur va prendre 24 heures au débat et
donc peu en tout cas entraîner le fait
que
le texte parte au Sénat sans qu'on ait
discuté
ça c'est l'argument de façade mais une
réalité ce qui gêne Fabien Roussel dans
cette histoire c'est de devoir voter
contre une motion de censure contre la
réforme des retraites c'est un contre
contre ça fait pour c'est à dire que
Fabien Roussel peut apparaître comme
soutien de la réforme des retraites
c'est un peu c'est vraiment de la
tactique de la tactique politique là qui
est un peu compliqué mais si vous ne
votez pas une réforme de sens une motion
de censure contre une réforme que vous
ne soutenez pas à ce moment-là c'est que
vous soutenez la réforme ils sont pris
ils sont pris en portefeuille
du second tour de la présidentielle
c'est-à-dire que c'est dire
vous vous avez pas vous voulez pas voté
pour moi vous votez pour Macron
personnalisé dans le cas du second tour
de l'élection présidentielle là c'est
vraiment sur un texte de loi mais le non
Marine Le Pen a bien joué le coup
beaucoup tactique donc
si malgré le coût tactique qui a été
joué vous ne pensez pas que cette
comment dire cette notion de censure va
être votée a priori il a quand même
aucune chance d'être adoptée il faudrait
vraiment un concours de circonstances
totalement invraisemblable pour que la
motion de censure soit adoptée la gauche
va voter contre elle va s'abstenir elle
a la gauche la voter contre la motion
mais c'est pour ça qu'ils sont fous
furieux d'ailleurs à gauche au PS chez
les Verts et la France
[Musique]
si vous retirez ce bloc d'amendement il
doit en rester des amendements de
lrrn renaissance enfin des autres des
autres groupes parlementaires mais si
vous retirez le bloc d'amendement de la
de la nups et de LFI vous pouvez avancer
très vite vers l'examen et le débat sur
l'article 7
les amendements actuels ils portent sur
les justes techniquement les articles
qui sont qui ont été votés ou qui il y a
beaucoup de n'importe quoi c'est
vraiment de l'obstruction parlementaire
et puis il y a des il y a des
amendements un peu plus techniques sur
le sur les femmes soit sur le tout un
tas de tout un tas de choses des
arguments disons sérieux mais vraiment
le gros des amendements ce qui
représente le gros du bloc des 4000 ce
qui qui empêche les débats d'arriver à
l'article 7 ce sont des amendements
d'obstruction 11000 amendements de jour
c'est quoi cette sidération le monde
lancèrent c'est compliqué d'ailleurs
d'examiner 11000 amendements c'est
impossible c'est impossible Marine Le
Pen expliquait hier d'ailleurs que au
rythme de un abonnement ex hi magnet
toutes les toutes les 10 minutes il
faudrait 1050 heures de débats donc même
en accélérant c'était impossible à tenir
Jean-Luc Mélenchon déclare déclaré tout
à l'heure que Emmanuel Macron ne voit
pas l'état de tension du pays c'est vrai
c'est faux
c'est difficile de répondre c'est
difficile de répondre parce qu'Emmanuel
Macron a vécu la crise des gilets jaunes
donc il a vécu un état de tension du
pays de de très très près est-ce que le
votre question ou la question de notre
internaute c'est est-ce que le président
est déconnecté la réalité du pays
en tout cas il y a une obsession de la
réforme des retraites chez Emmanuel
Macron pourquoi mais alors c'est une une
image
béton tendresse comme vous voudrez mais
ça fait 6 ans que Emmanuel Macron tourne
sur son manège et il essaie d'attraper
la queue du Mickey si l'attrape pas
cette fois il y aura pas de tour gratuit
pourquoi la réforme des retraites pour
reprendre votre image il a que du Mickey
parce que c'est la réforme emblématique
de réformisme que veut incarner Emmanuel
Macron cette réforme des retraites
celui on peut dire ceux qui ont réussi
entre guillemets c'est François Fillon
et Jean-Pierre Raffin tout le monde a
réussi avant lui c'est à dire que il y a
pas un président de la République qui
n'a pas fait ça sa réforme des retraites
il serait le premier à ne pas avoir
réussi à en faire une ça n'a pas marché
pendant son premier quinquennat pour des
à cause du covid pour notamment et puis
surtout parce que l'ambition initiale
d'Emmanuel Macron de mettre en place une
une réforme systémique sur quelque chose
d'extrêmement ambitieux à échouer et
qu'il a dû se rabattre sur le scénario
d'une réforme systémique ce qu'on fait
tous ces prédécesseurs
il faut quand même pour lui ça c'est la
forme de 2019 non il y a plus
d'informations c'était justement le
projet de réforme en 2019 c'était un non
même pas c'était c'était un projet
systémique
non justement c'était c'était déjà un
aménagement
qui était camouflé disons c'est c'était
pas la réforme systémique le le grand
chambardement qui était envisagé
initialement au départ le vraiment la
réforme
oui c'est tellement complexe qu'on
n'arrive pas même pas les qualifier la
réforme de
la réforme de 2000 disons plutôt la
réforme de 2017 c'était une réforme qui
devait fondre les 42 régimes spéciaux en
un seul régime unique pour tous les
Français ouais c'était quelque soit
l'autre métier quel que soit votre
profession votre parcours professionnel
vous aviez le même système de réformes
alors ça ça c'est heurté à des à des
conservatismes d'abord à des complexités
totalement invraisemblables ensuite qui
ont fait que le Edouard Philippe c'est
finalement rabattu sur une réforme qui
était autour de l'âge pivot pour partir
en retraite enfin avec un report de
légal de départ et un âge pivot pour
toucher sa retraite à taux plein qui
était aussi compliqué mais qui était
déjà quelque part une réforme
paramétrique là aujourd'hui on revient
sur une là on est totalement dans la
réforme paramétrique c'est on
essaie enfin pas le refaire mais il y a
des trois paramètres dans une réforme
des retraites
de départ niveau des pensions et taux de
cotisation voilà si vous la réforme
paramétrique c'est vous touchez un de
ces trois paramètres donc là on est là
dedans avec l'âge de départ
on va se quitter mais juste quelques
questions à avoir avec vous François
Xavier sur la bataille de l'opinion
qu'est-ce qui espère le gouvernement
aujourd'hui rien ils l'ont perdu donc la
seule chose qui puisse arriver de bien
au gouvernement c'est que les grèves et
les manifestations dégénères et que
l'opinion se retourne gêné par le par le
par les grèves les trains enfin tout
c'est tout ce qu'on voit d'habitude dans
un mouvement social contre contre la
réforme des retraites or pour l'instant
les syndicats jouent de façon très
habile en empêchant justement de qui est
trop de désagréments pour les usagers et
on voit que le mouvement est plutôt
plutôt soutenu dans l'opinion donc pour
l'instant là la bataille de l'opinion
elle était perdue par le par le
gouvernement à l'entrée de la réforme
des retraites et il y a plus beaucoup
d'espoir de la de la remparté de la
reporter sauf si le mouvement social
l'apprend d'autres formes blocage des
raffineries blocage des transports de
transport aérien routier vraiment il
faudrait que le
conflit social entre dans une nouvelle
phase pour l'instant on parie sur un
vote ou on commence à envisager le
49-39-3 c'est le dernier scénario c'est
vraiment le scénario catastrophe auquel
gouvernement absolument pas recourir et
qui serait parce qu'il serait sans doute
très très dangereux pour le
l'acceptation sociale de la réforme dans
le pays qui est réforme qui est déjà
rejeté donc vous rajoutez du 49-3 par
dessus c'est compliqué le scénario
privilégié c'est évidemment à votre
majoritaire c'est le scénario le plus
probable mais le gouvernement n'est pas
à l'abri d'un coup de théâtre ou d'un
rebondissement dans l'hémicycle je vous
dis c'est on a du mal à saisir ça mais
c'est vraiment ce chaudron de
l'hémicycle et tout peut arriver est-ce
que quand bien même la réforme serait
votée on craint au gouver au niveau
gouvernemental un scénario à la CPE
c'est à dire une loi a été voté mais
sous la sous la pression de la rue c'est
pas d'autre qui a été retiré c'était
voilà l'expression de de Jacques Chirac
c'était elle était promulguée suspendue
il avait promulgué il l'avait suspendu
là non une fois que ce sera voté
et c'est tout le CFA c'est tout le
l'enjeu pour le pour Emmanuel Macron de
passer ce texte à l'Assemblée nationale
parce qu'après vous opposez à
la rue la légitimité du Parlement et
c'est un autre et on entre dans un autre
débat où là le France syndical peut se
fissurer est-ce qu'on est-ce que
Emmanuel Macron peut encore lâcher du
lest il y a quelques petites choses
encore sur le travail des femmes
notamment mais le ils ont déjà beaucoup
lâché et par rapport aux économies
attendues dans la mouture initiale de la
réforme de retraite qui était de 18
milliards d'euros il faudrait pas que
cette réforme finisse par coûter plus
cher coûter plus qu'elle nous rapporte
on n'est pas loin là bah ça commence à
être un peu compliqué là c'est c'est
faudrait pas que ça se rapproche une
réforme pour rien alors là c'est un
petit peu le l'image de la fuite dans la
digue tu sais il y avait une petite
brèche dans une digue et un peu d'eau
qui s'écoule et puis ça finit par
creuser ça creuser ça le barrage
s'effondre et c'est en porte toute la
vallée c'est c'est vraiment le risque
qui affrontent en ce moment-là merci
beaucoup à François-Xavier pour tous ces
éclairages toutes ces toutes ces
informations toutes ces précisions et
puis ces infos également que vous avez
glanées et qu'on peut lire bien entendu
sur le Figaro et je recommande tous vos
ouvrages sur sur Emmanuel Macron et en
particulier le dernier que j'avais écrit
avec Charles
tango des fois de l'archipel merci
beaucoup
Xavier ben on va regarder un petit peu
voir l'ambiance de ce qui se passe
actuellement à Paris ou bah selon nos
confrères sur place l'ambiance est calme
très calme sauf énorme surprise nous dit
Vladimir Garcin il n'y aura pas de
violence aujourd'hui à Paris c'est hyper
calme voir endormi voilà donc et ben je
vous laisse dans cette dans cette
ambiance un peu calme avant de retrouver
Arthur byzota avec qui nous allons faire
un point sur la mobilisation allez plein
pot et à tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
15h34 on continue de suivre cette
mobilisation cette cinquième journée de
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites donc actuellement en
discussion à l'Assemblée discussions
âpre nous disait à l'instant
François-Xavier Bourdeau du Figaro
politique on continuera on va continuer
de suivre tout au long de l'après-midi
ces mobilisations avec différents
éclairages notamment on viendra
également sur ce qui se passe sur au
plan sécuritaire entre ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui ce qui peut se passer plus
tard avec Christophe cornavat ou bien
avec Sophie dravinal un peu lequel
l'ambiance à gauche et Marie Bizot
l'impact économique de ces
manifestations et on reviendra également
à la fin de cela et sur la question du
jour le mouvement social contre la
réforme des retraites est-il en train de
s'essouffler bah ça ça nous fait une
excellente
ça nous fait une excellente transition
pour en parler déjà une première fois
avec vous Arthur bijouta d'abord
peut-être une question on l'a vu tout à
l'heure des images d'Albi dans le Tarn
ou s'était lancé le cortège avec à sa
tête donc la terre syndicale oui leader
syndicaux
6000 manifestants pour 50000 habitants
la semaine dernière est-ce que
la alors c'était peut-être pas tous des
habitants d'Albi mais en tous les cas on
était plus de 10% de la de la population
albigeoise
est-ce que la performance est atteinte
encore aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on a des
indicateurs déjà de ça la performance à
Albi on ne sait pas encore on sait que
les syndicats attendent au moins 30 000
manifestants donc pour une ville de
50000 habitants on va battre évidemment
tous les records mais c'est vrai que ces
chiffres de 10% de la population 10% de
l'agglomération ou 10% de l'aire urbaine
pardon comme le de l'Insee c'est des
chiffres qu'on a vu qu'on a vu beaucoup
à de nombreuses dans plusieurs villes
dans beaucoup de villes du Sud-Ouest
dans beaucoup de villes bretonnes
également en quelques villes du Nord-Est
ce sont des chiffres qu'on a beaucoup vu
lors des quatre premières journées de
mobilisation des chiffres qu'on verra à
mon avis beaucoup moins aujourd'hui
alors justement je regardais la carte
que vous faites alors que je regarde sur
le live texte du Figaro 8000
manifestants selon la préfecture 30 000
selon les syndicats c'est en tout cas en
dessous de la marge de du 11 février de
samedi dernier ou et il y avait à
l'époque
13500 selon les préfectures et et 80000
selon l'intersyndical donc on est
vraiment en baisse en tous les cas dans
la préfecture de la nouvelle Aquitaine
j'ai regardé votre carte tout à l'heure
à part dans le Nord ça en tout cas à la
mi-journée ça a baissait un peu partout
effectivement elle a mi-journée donc sur
les peut-être un peu plus d'une centaine
de villes dont on a pu recueillir le
nombre de manifestants selon les
autorités on était à 208 000
manifestants aujourd'hui pour ces mêmes
villes à la même heure samedi on était à
115 000 c'est pour ainsi dire du simple
double donc on pourrait tabler sur une
mobilisation finale autour d'un peu
moins de 500 000 manifestants tout en
sachant que dans de nombreuses villes et
parfois même des grandes villes je pense
à Nantes je pense à Angers les
manifestations vont avoir lieu vers
17h30 18h 18h30 ce sera des retraites en
flambeau il faudra voir à quel moment le
ministère de l'Intérieur va donner ses
chiffres et s'il les prend en compte etc
etc en tout cas on les a pas donc on les
on va on va attendre un peu avant de les
avoir on aura peut-être quand même des
chiffres sur des chiffres à Paris deux
chiffres à Paris vu le l'avancée rapide
voire même endormi nous disait Vladimir
Garcin il y a quelques instants du
cortège effectivement on peut espérer
des chiffres avant avant 17h des
chiffres avant 17h justement ce sera on
aura tout à fait le loisir et l'occasion
l'opportunité de vous les donner
il y a une nouvelle mobilisation quand
même ça qui est intéressant dans votre
carte tout à l'heure celle que vous avez
publié aussi du Figaro et le figata il y
a des nouvelles il y a des nouvelles
mobilisations dans certaines villes
effectivement on a quelques nouvelles
mobilisations mais après on joue
beaucoup sur l'alternance je pense par
exemple un premier exemple qui me vient
en tête c'est la Mayenne la Mayenne ou
on avait fait tous les défilés à Laval
et aujourd'hui on a décidé de faire deux
défilés dans les deux sous-préfectures à
Château-Gontier et à Mayenne Mayenne
dans la Mayenne c'est assez simple à
retenir donc il y a parfois quelques
petites subtilités qui nous qui nous
comment dire qui nous qui sont visibles
et qui et qui permettent d'expliquer ces
nouvelles manifestations c'est pas qu'il
y a plus de défilé c'est qu'ils sont
répartis différemment la stratégie assez
précisément de disséminer
ces manifestations
pour cacher les baisses ou bien pour
créer un levier supplémentaire de
mobilisation je vais vous faire une
réponse de Normand un peu des deux
effectivement je pense que comme les
syndicats s'attendaient ils l'avaient
dit Philippe Martinez a dit aujourd'hui
en arrivant à Albi que les chiffres ne
comptaient pas donc les syndicats
s'attendaient à une vraie baisse de la
mobilisation c'est la troisième journée
de mobilisation 10 jours donc ça
commence à peser ne serait-ce que pour
les gens qui font grève et qui perdent à
chaque fois une journée de salaire donc
les syndicats s'attendaient à une baisse
de la mobilisation ils ont multiplié les
petits défilés peut-être un peu pour
cacher cacher tout ça mais je pense
qu'il y a également une véritable
stratégie de de marquer le territoire de
se dire là on a défilé tel jour là on a
défilé tel autre jour pour que le 7 mars
lors de la grande journée de
mobilisation qui s'annonce il y est
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de monde
est-ce que la sociologie reste toujours
la même
pour l'instant on voit les toujours les
mêmes départements qui qui qui manifeste
le plus on a publié ce matin une carte
dans le journal qui concerne
spécifiquement la Bretagne même si on
voit une baisse de la mobilisation à
Morlaix à Lannion etc etc en Bretagne du
Nord en Bretagne du Nord il y a toujours
une plus forte mobilisation dans ces
régions de l'ouest par rapport à des
régions de l'Est ça c'est pour la
géographie pour la sociologie est-ce que
on observe toujours une forte
mobilisation de la france ouvrière et de
la France des services publics oui on
peut tout à fait prendre l'exemple
d'Albi Albi qui est la terre de Jean
Jaurès qui a été député de Carmaux et
qui est né à Castres si ma mémoire est
bonne là où les leaders syndicaux vont
manifester aujourd'hui donc c'est une
France qui est quand même l'habitude de
défiler qui est syndiquée qui est très
attaché au service à l'époque industriel
et minière industrielle et minières qui
a l'habitude également du service public
dans de nombreux petits départements je
pense à l'Indre où il y avait encore
3000 à 35 se manifestants à Château
Rouge aujourd'hui c'est des départements
où le nombre de fonctionnaires et le
plus élevé en France donc on voit une
véritable corrélation entre la présence
de nombreux fonctionnaires et la
présence de nombreux manifestants
on voit que la CGT annonce 300000
manifestants à Paris elle en avait
annoncé 500 000 samedi alors sans
regarder la réalité des chiffres par
contre il y a la réalité des tendances
donc là apparemment la société reconnaît
qui aurait une baisse en tout cas en
terme de tendance oui on est entre - là
la CGT ça fait -40% entre 500.000 samedi
et 300 000 aujourd'hui on est vraiment
sur les sur les 108 109 villes qu'on a
analysé à l'heure actuelle on est
vraiment sur ce genre de tendance nous
on est à -50%, peut-être que la
mobilisation d'Albi va faire remonter un
petit peu ce chiffre mais on sera entre
-40 et - 50% à la fin de la journée sans
aucun doute est-ce qu'il y a une
évolution au niveau des slogans en tout
cas de ce qu'on peut voir en termes de
de motif de organisation notamment dans
ces villes moyennes dans cette ville ce
que nous rapporte nos confrères de la
presse quotidienne régionale qui sont
sur le terrain et avec qui sur lesquels
on s'appuie pour pour prendre ses
chiffres c'est que les motivations sont
toujours les mêmes mais que dans
beaucoup de cortèges ce qui revenaient
ce matin et c'est ce qui m'a marqué
c'est que les gens se disaient on va se
réserver un petit peu on va souffler un
petit peu pendant ces deux semaines et
demi sans mobilisation et on veut tous
on veut vraiment faire un gros coup
entre guillemets le 7 juin le 7 mars
pardon c'est vraiment ce qui revient
dans dans toutes les manifestations
les gens disaient ce n'est pas grave
qu'il y ait moins de monde ce n'est pas
grave que la mobilisation soit en baisse
ce n'est pas un essoufflement c'est plus
une préparation pour le 7 mars est-ce
que il y a pas aussi un phénomène
indépendamment du fait que les deux
tiers des du pays étant en vacances
scolaires
en tout cas deux zones sur trois
est-ce que il y a pas un phénomène
également de de manifestations en
semaine il y a beaucoup de questions et
de remarques de personnes qui
soutiennent cette mobilisation qui
s'exprime sur cette chatte à la fois sur
le chat du Figaro et sur le chat de
YouTube vous continuez qui disent mais
si il y avait une manifestation le
samedi il y aura eu plus de monde
effectivement les syndicats ont joué
cette carte du de la manifestation le
samedi qui permet à la fois aux gens en
vacances à la fois aux gens qui n'ont
plus les moyens de faire grève donc de
perdre une journée de salaire d'aller
manifester mais ils l'ont joué une fois
la jouer deux fois en deux semaines je
pense que ça aurait été trop rapproché
là vous avez quand même quasiment
presque les trois zones en vacances la
zone C la zone Paris Montpellier va
l'être demain soir donc les syndicats
ont préféré attendre laisser passer les
vacances scolaires laisser passer un
temps de respiration que les paye
tombent il faut il faut parler
clairement pour pour ceux qui pour les
grévistes avant de réenchaîner sur une
mobilisation plus forte et qui
correspondra également
au calendrier parlementaire la réforme
sera ne sera pas n'aura pas été votée
dans son ensemble le 7 mars donc c'est
aussi pour ça qu'ils ont choisi cette
date un manifestant pour vous donner un
petit peu en tous les cas une idée de
l'ambiance à Paris dit à notre confrère
Vladimir Garcin qu'est-ce qu'on
s'emmerde dans cette manifestation si
c'est ça la tête des glaces voilà donc
c'est l'ambiance en tous les cas est
plutôt calme et et effectivement en
dormant pour reprendre et endormi pour
reprendre l'expression tout à l'heure de
Vladimir Garcin PAO nous dit sur Youtube
non le Figaro non le mouvement ne
souffle pas il attend l'étincelle
quelques d'ailleurs quelques violences
sont signalées en ce moment à Lyon on y
reviendra dans un quart d'heure avec
Christophe Cornavin
qui suit les questions de sécurité et de
police
dans les sociétés du Figaro 930
000 c'était le nombre de manifestants
en tout cas samedi 1939 c'était le
nombre de manifestants donnés par le
ministère intérieur est-ce qu'il faut
croire à ces chiffres officiels ou
est-ce qu'il y avait plus ou moins de
manifestants alors sur le haut niveau
des chiffres officiels qu'on reprend en
Figaro tous nos chiffres sont les
chiffres donnés par les renseignements
généraux par la préfecture par la
gendarmerie locale on peut par exemple
s'appuyer sur les comptages qui sont
faits par nos confrères de la presse
quotidienne régionale la plupart du
temps les comptages de nos confrères
sont proches voir les mêmes que ceux de
la police ils sont assez éloignés de ce
des syndicats même si samedi il y a eu
un véritable écart à Saint-Étienne par
exemple il y a eu une un comptage
préfecture qui a été dénoncé dans la
presse je pense notamment au progrès
comme comme peu vraisemblable on ne
montage à la baisse un comptage à la
baisse et dénoncer comme peu
vraisemblable car il y avait plus de
manifestants à Roanne qu'à Saint-Étienne
ce qui si on connaît les deux villes et
la taille des villes semble vraiment peu
probable donc samedi il y a eu je pense
je ne sais pas si c'est volontaire ou
pas je ne me prononcerai pas là-dessus
mais en tout cas les chiffres donnés par
nos confrères de la presse quotidienne
régionale était légèrement plus élevé
que ceux des autorités alors que
d'habitude ils sont quand même très très
très proches là on revient avec des
chiffres PQR presque qui viennent
régionales très proche de ceux de la
police donc je pense que que ces
chiffres sont justes si on raisonne en
termes sociologique
où il y a-t-il une augmentation et où il
y a-t-il une
décroissance aujourd'hui la baisse est
vraiment générale je pourrais uniquement
citer Dieppe qui avait 1400 manifestants
samedi et qui en a 1800 aujourd'hui je
crois
je crois que c'est notre une seule ville
où la mobilisation est en hausse tout le
reste c'est soit des nouvelles
mobilisations mais comme j'ai expliqué
tout à l'heure c'est des questions de
géographie et de et de choix sinon
toutes les autres villes sont en baisse
et il y a des baisses plus ou moins
marquées mais je pense que dans les
grandes villes il y a une vraie vraie
vraie vraie baisse de la mobilisation
parce que samedi ils ont battu des
records Rennes a battu un record samedi
avec 25000 ils étaient 6700 aujourd'hui
Marseille ils étaient 12000 la semaine
en fin de semaine dernière ils étaient
7000 aujourd'hui donc la baisse est un
petit peu plus accentuée sur les grandes
villes en tout cas aujourd'hui
en termes de secteurs d'activité on voit
une hausse quand même dans certains
secteurs en tout cas de mobilisation en
termes de grève
notamment dans l'énergie chez les jeunes
oui la jeunesse est appelée j'ai vu par
les syndicats étudiants à se mobiliser
tous les jeudis jusqu'au 7 mars et
pourquoi pas faire le entre guillemets
le pont avec la mobilisation du 7 mars
le 8 mars la Journée de la femme et le 9
mars une mobilisation de la jeunesse
effectivement
on va on voit beaucoup beaucoup de
jeunes dans les cortèges et parfois
également des jeunes qui sont rentrés
chez leurs parents des jeunes étudiants
qui sont rentrés chez leurs parents et
qui manifestent dans la dans la petite
ville dans la petite sous-préfecture
dans la préfecture chez local entre
est-ce que
il y a un autre secteur bon je vous ai
parlé de la jeunesse celui de l'énergie
aussi celui de l'énergie très importante
on sait qu'au début de la mobilisation
les raffineries avaient appelé à une
mobilisation sur deux trois quatre jours
faisant revenir le spectre d'une pénurie
à la pompe comme on en a connu au mois
de octobre et novembre dernier pour
l'instant on
pas encore se dessiner un tel scénario
il faudra voir
comment ça va se dessiner avant le 7
mars savoir si les grèves seront
reconductibles mais effectivement la CGT
énergie est très très mobilisée j'ai vu
qu'ils avaient fait baisser la
production d'électricité de 3000
mégawatt ce matin
est-ce que vous parliez justement tout à
l'heure de la mobilisation des étudiants
avec un pont possible entre le 7 8 et le
9 mars est-ce que on doit se préparer en
tout cas un blocage étudiant et un
blocage des facs certaines facultés
étaient déjà bloquées elles ont été
bloquées on pense à l'intervention du
député la France insoumise Louis Baya
Louis Boyard pardon à Rennes 2 qui avait
entraîné ensuite un blocage le campus de
de Tolbiac qui appartient à la Faculté
Paris Panthéon Sorbonne a également été
bloqué ce matin oui on peut tout à fait
s'attendre à des blocages de facultés à
partir partir du 7 mars et on c'est
difficile à prédire mais en tout cas on
sent que cette date du 7 mars elle est
déjà dans toutes les têtes aujourd'hui
et les manifestants ceux qui sont
mobilisés dans la rue ne pensent
véritablement qu'à cette date et les
chiffres sont seront à scruter ce
jour-là avec avec grande attention je
réponds à Rome 37 91 qui nous dit que il
faut sortir du Figaro et de la pensée
caniveau pour les nuls je vous en prie
et si c'est très bien il faut pas vous
faire du mal mais
je vous prie de rester quand même dans
le le cadre des chartes de modération et
effectivement tous les débats tous les
opinions sont encendables mais je peux
pas entendre que ici c'est la pensée
caniveau
un dernier point quels sont les
aujourd'hui les
les villes et en tous les cas les
secteurs que vous guettez pour le fil
data et maintenant et dans les heures à
venir on guette l'ensemble des 250
mobilisations en France on avait un œil
ce matin sur les quelques manifestations
dans des préfectures par je pense par
exemple à Bourges où ils étaient
uniquement 2000 contre 3600 samedi et où
leur record c'est 5000 donc tout de
suite avec ces villes là on voit se
dessiner une tendance je pensais
également un Bergerac c'était 5000
samedi ils sont plus que 2000
aujourd'hui donc c'est ces petites
villes là dès le matin qui manifeste à
9h30 10h 11h qui nous permettent ensuite
de dessiner la grande tendance pour pour
aujourd'hui et la tendance elle est à
une baisse une mobilisation divisée par
deux environ merci beaucoup arthurby
pour ces précisions et pour ces
informations je rappelle que tout ce qui
est
fait je salue ns qui nous rejoint Alain
également qui est avec nous euh les je
précise d'ailleurs donc que tout ce qui
est fait en termes de chiffres c'est
retrouver à la fois dans Live texte du
Figaro qui est en dessous de ce player
mais également dans la rubrique
figatable très intéressante passionnant
et avec des éclairages très souvent
également de de spécialistes et bien sûr
dans les pages du Figaro
et de Figaro écrite on continue le
débattre on commente on reste calme sur
les formes du figaos c'est pas la peine
de de s'énerver et de et de de
s'invctiver on évite les épithètes voilà
on réagit on regarde donc c'est ces
images et on commente ce débat sur la
réforme des retraites qui finalement
intéresse pas mal de monde même si la
manifestation la mobilisation semble en
bâche en baisse
aujourd'hui pardon notamment ici à Paris
300 000 selon la CGT contre 500 000
samedi et également
des manifestations en baisse dans la
plupart du temps dans les régions et
également là où on a vu un certain
nombre de de mobilisation jusqu'à
présent dans les petites villes et on va
regarder si on va atteindre les 30000 à
Albi
vous prenez un pari je prends c'est
difficile de prendre les paris mais en
tout cas si on en croit les chiffres
depuis le début de la matinée on sera
légèrement en dessous des 500 000
manifestants en tous les cas pour pour
aujourd'hui c'était ce qui est prévu 500
000 c'est ce qui était prévu maximum par
les par les autorités merci beaucoup on
va regarder également ce qui se passe au
plan sécurité dans quelques minutes avec
Christophe Cornavin en attendant je vous
laisse avec ces images de de
manifestations qu'on va continuer à
vivre et on revient pour les pour les
commentaires juste après
[Musique]
un endroit où manifestations
et encore
[Musique]
c'est pour moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
petit Garros c'est Figaro live pardon
16h et nous sommes toujours en direct
dans les studios du Figaro poursuivre et
pour faire vivre cette cinquième journée
de mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites 5e journée de mobilisation
contre la réforme des retraites on va
arriver à articuler et on a le plaisir
d'être avec Christophe Cornavin
spécialiste des questions de
renseignement intérieur également de
sécurité au service sociétés du Figaro
extrêmement affûté et renseigné aux
meilleures sources alors première
question mon cher Christophe à quoi déjà
s'attendait aujourd'hui les
renseignements territoriaux alors on
s'attendait à une influence qui était
quand même mobilisation qui était quand
même en baisse entre 450 et 650 000
personnes c'est beaucoup moins que que
la précédente édition l'acte 4 et c'est
presque la moitié du pic qu'on avait
enregistré le 31
janvier dernier donc c'est à dire que
les renseignements
l'extérieur notre s'attendait
véritablement à une à une un reflux
démobilisation et son terrain vous dites
si vrai parce que là vous Vladimir
garçonne nous signale que les syndicats
arrivent Place d'Italie terme de la
manifestation ici à Paris avec trois
heures d'avance oui ça prouve
qu'évidemment les les contingents sont
beaucoup plus clairsemés que ce qu'on
pouvait imaginer j'ai échangé là avec
avec un responsable des forces de
l'ordre qui nous disaient que il y a une
demi-heure que selon lui les estimations
les cortèges sont en baisse de 30 à 50%
par rapport à samedi c'est-à-dire qu'on
est vraiment en période de très basseaux
il y a alors on les a vu un des villes
comme comme Toulouse on a 14000
personnes versus 30 000
moitié moins c'est la moitié pareil à
pareil à Montpellier pareil à Marseille
en fait on peut lui aussi Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
et pourtant et il arrive pas à mobiliser
ça marche plus enfin en tout cas ça ne
marche pas et en fait ça s'explique pour
plusieurs raisons en fait pour les pour
les services de renseignement il y a
plusieurs choses ils avaient été un peu
surpris il faut quand même le
reconnaître le 19 janvier pendant l'acte
1 du mouvement
il s'attendait pas à notamment à cette à
cette colère qui montait dans ce qu'ils
appellent la France des sous-préfectures
donc les petites et moyennes villes de
France en revanche là on a des
indicateurs objectifs c'est à dire que
on sait qu'il y a l'effet vacances des
zones des zones A et des zones B il y a
un phénomène de lassitude aussi qui est
assez palpable on le voit dans les dans
les dans les cortèges les les
manifestants sont à leur quatrième
journée nationale d'action là c'est la
cinquième ils ont
ils ont en perspective le 7 mars qui
sera pour eux l'épreuve de force le
moment de vérité et puis il y a aussi
cette
oui c'est ça ce côté ce côté ça sert
plus rien en ce moment de descendre dans
la rue il faut garder les forces
garder du tonus pour pour cette pour ce
grand bras de fer du 7 du 7 mars c'est
en tout cas ce qui se dit et ce qui
était relevé notamment par les services
à travers le pays est-ce que le
ministère de l'Intérieur se félicite et
s'attribue le calme des manifestations
on va dire que il a dans sa matière dans
sa manière de gérer les foules notamment
à Paris parce que c'est souvent Paris
l'indicateur
global de la de la tendance la couleur
du ciel
à Paris ils sont assez honnêtes en
disant que c'est un double effet il y a
un effet évidemment qui est lié à la
mise en place d'un dispositif qui a
changé on a changé de posture dans le
maintien de l'ordre c'est-à-dire qu'on
est plus sur des policiers qui vont
directement en contact des manifestants
ce qu'on appelle flan garder les
cortèges c'est-à-dire de part et d'autre
de l'endroit et flanc gauche mettre des
forces de l'ordre qui sont en contact là
c'est plus le cas on les a retirés ils
sont devenus invisibles dans les rues
adjacentes donc ça calme c'est de nature
à calmer un peu les cortèges de tête qui
sont très violents où on trouve toute
cette fameuse galaxie avec les Black
Blocs autonome les
tous les activistes impossible et
imaginables comme ils voient pas des
policiers ils ont pas trop le pushing
bol ils ont pas de chiffon rouge ils ont
pas la muleta pour foncer donc on sait
pas trop donc ils peuvent pas s'attaque
parfois des banques etc mais c'est très
très c'est très sporadique là j'ai eu
notamment j'aimerais recevoir un message
pour dire qu'il y a des éléments
radicaux qui actuellement sont en train
de de dessouder je lis un panneau de
signalisation sur la voie publique pour
attaquer une banque boulevard de
l'Hôpital mais généralement ce qui se
passe c'est qu'à au moment même où
l'exaction commence les forces de
l'ordre qui sont en périphérie
fonce c'est-à-dire qu'en fait c'est pas
des policiers normaux ni des gendarmes
normaux on prend les bras les brigades
antiques on prend les pelotons
d'intervention de la gendarmerie qui
sont des militaires spécialisés dans le
saute dessus si vous me passez cette
expression pour passer les menottes et
intervenir au cœur de au cœur des
émeutiers cibler les meneurs et les
arrêter parce que finalement dans le
changement de doctrine il n'y a pas
simplement le fait de ne pas aller au
contact il y a la nature enfin en tous
les cas des dispositifs il y a la le
dispositifs ne sont pas les mêmes c'est
c'est plus de la Sûreté urbaine hein
complètement changé disons que quand
vous regardez des des dispositifs de
maintien de l'ordre en 60 litres vous
avez la tortue romaine avec des murs de
bouclier statique qui font face à 150
mètres des manifestants et reçoivent une
pluie projectile sans bouger on n'est
plus du tout dans cette posture là
maintenant la doctrine est plutôt celle
d'une relative discrétion au moment de
du passage du défilé une mise en retrait
d'efforts et
en revanche une force d'action rapide
fulgurante je dirais qui qui fonce sur
les sur les sur les fauteurs de troubles
et qui procèdent à l'interpellation
avant que ça déborde
la nature des interventions c'est pas
forcément des interventions
il y a peut-être moins d'intervention
mais ces interventions pardonnez-moi
mais c'est un peu plus radical même que
ce qu'on a vu au moment des gilets
jaunes
oui ça en tout cas c'est radical dans la
mesure où on est vraiment presque dans
des opérations bac des opérations
anti-criminalité ou ou véritablement là
il s'agit de
faire éclater ce qu'ils disent c'est le
vocabulaire que les forces de l'ordre
emploi en interne c'est faire éclater
les Black Blocs donc leur foncer dedans
les faire voler les émietter et faire
une frappe chirurgicale au milieu pour
pour les arrêter ça c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles en fait pour
l'instant ça ne bouge pas mais l'autre
raison qui est aussi important que la
première à mon sens c'est que nous
sommes dans des cortèges syndicaux ou à
la différence des gilets jaunes vous
avez des services d'ordre extrêmement
conséquent notamment ceux de la CGT qui
sont encore garnis de de gros bras des
gens qui ont travaillé sur les docks qui
vont travailler dans des usines qui sont
de solides Gaillard et qui sont
parfaitement organisés pour protéger le
rang de leur défilé donc ça c'est voilà
il y a les deux choses c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a les forces de l'ordre qui ont
changé de posture de doctrine et par
ailleurs donc ces services d'ordre
ces services d'ordre des syndicats
images donc de la place d'Italie
justement qui est la destination finale
de ce cortège le cortège continue ceci
dit mais destination finale de cette
manifestation ou la tête de
manifestation la tête de cortège à Paris
arrive avec plus de 3 heures d'avance
ici
donc dans le 13e arrondissement de Paris
est-ce qu'on craint une radicalisation
si ça baisse précisément si ce genre
d'image se confirme si et si la réforme
a une chance de passer
évidemment évidemment parce que pour
l'instant
on pourrait imaginer finalement que les
que les que les casseurs
ils sont en embuscade ne bouge pas ils
sont là on estime qu'en France il y a
trois deux à trois mille casseurs qui
gravitent notamment dans le dans les
mouvances anarchotonome et d'ultra
gauche ces gens là ils vont pas ils vont
pas lâcher l'affaire ils sont
extrêmement mobiles ils sont extrêmement
motivés et ils attendent la première
occasion la première friabilité dans le
dispositif si les syndicats se rendent
compte que
ça ne marche pas que les manifestations
de runes ne marchent pas on peut très
bien imaginer un moment ou un autre que
la brèche s'ouvre un petit peu et que
tout d'un coup le le les éléments
violents puissent enfin laisser libre
cours alors déluge de haine et de
d'agression contre les policiers datax
ciblés contre les symboles du
capitalisme etc et pour faire dévisser
complètement ce mouvement il faut quand
même bien se souvenir que parmi les
manifestants actuellement il y a
beaucoup de gens qui se disent
on en est à la cinquième manifestation
finalement on a eu que des broutilles
les gilets jaunes eux
à la fin du mouvement ils ont quand même
un énorme chèque
des pouvoirs publics et donc ils
auraient à la conclusion hélas que c'est
la violence qui paye voilà
un secteur se mobilise plus aujourd'hui
c'est l'énergie est-ce qu'on craint un
blocus au niveau de l'essence
alors on craint un blocus au niveau de
l'essence mais pas mais pas que je veux
dire il y a des
rassurant ce que vous dites non mais oui
parce qu'en fait ce qui se passe c'est
que à partir du 7 mars on varie on va on
va changer de dimension on va changer de
paradigme c'est à dire que quand on
vient de l'expliquer les mouvements de
la rue
ont leur limite même s'il y a beaucoup
de gens les syndicats ont compris que ça
ne va pas infléchir la la
posture du gouvernement et donc l'idée
c'est que le 7 mars va être certainement
un moment de fracture dans le front
syndical c'est à dire que les
réformistes de la CFDT vont essayer
d'être toujours partisans du dialogue en
revanche ils appellent quand même la
grève générale les appellent la grève
générale mais il mais je ne pense pas
qu'ils iront jusqu'à des des stratégies
de de blocage en force comme le veut la
CGT parce qu'on sait déjà que dans les
secteurs donc vous parliez du carburant
mais donc c'est l'énergie mais aussi les
secteurs des Mines le secteur d'époque
des ports et des docks et celui des
transports routiers et des transports
ferroviaires tous ces secteurs sont vont
virer à l'écarlate à partir du 7 mars
donc c'est à dire que on risque d'avoir
comme une paralysie du pays des
thrombose sur les roues routes enfin
c'est ce sera pas le grand soir mais ce
sera un je pense qu'on va arriver dans
une France paralysée en tout cas c'est
jouable et c'est quand même des scènes
qui sont
voisines un peu du chaos que vous
décrivez là c'est un peu ben en fait oui
c'est le pays de la connu on a déjà
connu des grandes grèves comme ça on est
on est proche en tout cas alors du chaos
en tout cas d'une paralysie totale et et
qui mettra qui risque de mettre
l'économie du pays durablement
hors circuit parce que parce que c'est
vrai que on a eu quand même on a eu on a
eu les gilets jaunes enfin les
commerçants on parleront mieux que
personne mais ils ont eu quand même un
certain nombre de problèmes à essuyer
les uns vers les autres en parlant
passant par la pandémie etc maintenant
il craignent tout ça d'être terrassé par
par une une mutation et métamorphose de
la grande sociale qui va toucher de
plein fouet l'économie
on va voir justement ça dans un instant
enfin en tous les cas après vous avec la
Marie Viso du Figaro économique
précisément
il y a un autre secteur en tous les cas
a eu notre groupe qui se mobilise c'est
la jeunesse est-ce qu'on craint en tous
les cas une contagion dans les facs dans
les universités et au niveau de la
jeunesse
style 86 style CPE etc oui bien sûr en
fait c'est en fait les
les analystes du ministère de
l'Intérieur regardent comme le lait sur
le feu tout ce qui est lié à la jeunesse
parce que si la jeunesse qu'elle soit
lycéenne ou étudiante rejoint le
mouvement celui-ci va
une nouvelle fois changer de nature ça
va ça pose toujours d'énormes problèmes
en termes de maintien de l'ordre parce
que quand vous avez déjà des enfants
dans des cortèges pour les forces c'est
beaucoup plus difficile à manœuvrer pour
intervenir pour être plus délicat et
puis ils ont tous encore l'empreinte
traumatique de la mort de Maliko sicine
1986 à 200-19
qui est passée chez Disney plus
exactement et en fait ça c'est
ça reste en croissante un peu les esprit
des forces de l'ordre donc les jeunes
c'est vraiment un marqueur en plus
est-ce qu'on prévoit justement une
montée en puissance d'un mouvement
d'opposition et de mobilisation dans
ce secteur de la population pour
l'instant alors on en parle certaines
grosses crainte au tout début d'ailleurs
les manières les manifestants les les
syndicats appelaient la phase lunaire
enfin comme d'habitude à plaire à
reverser la table et ouais les syndicat
étudiants et pour l'instant les blocages
restent extrêmement limités dans les
lycées les âgés sont embryonnaires dans
les facs
rappelons que ce sont on est en période
de vacances pas pour tous les étudiants
mais pour un certain nombre donc et puis
il y a aussi des étudiants qui passent
actuellement des partiels donc ce sera
très intéressant de voir comment tout ça
évolue en mars quand tout d'un coup il y
aura cette cette montée en puissance de
la de la colère à partir du 7 donc vous
parlez Christophe dans le live texte du
Figaro on voit bien que les la
mobilisation en tous les cas baisse dans
un certain nombre d'endroits à commencer
par la troisième ville de France la
ville de Lyon qui
on voit que le cortège rassemble moitié
moins de manifester ce jeudi donc on
disait tout à l'heure moitié moins à
Toulouse moitié moins également à Lyon
et c'est une tendance que l'on voit
quand même dans pas mal de villes grâce
à la carte qui a été établie et dressée
par le figata on voit bien qu'il y a une
baisse on le disait donc à Lyon à
Marseille la deuxième Île-de-France
Montpellier Bordeaux également Nice
vraiment beaucoup moins Strasbourg
également baisse baisse à Rouen baisse à
Tours ben sa reine pas de baisse pour
l'instant noté à Nantes ou à Paris ou à
Toulon ou encore à Lille mais là encore
je pense qu'il va falloir avoir les les
chiffres et les tendances sachant comme
le disait également tout à l'heure
Arthur bijouta qui a des mobilisations
qui sont prévues en fin d'après-midi et
qui sont prévus ce soir avec des
retraites au flambeau sur ça il y a des
inquiétudes
notamment notamment notamment à Nantes
en fait il y a dans les
ce qui inquiète toujours ce sont les
villes où les les militants d'ultra
gauche sont sont nombreux donc les
berceaux de l'ultra gauche Rennes
c'est toujours un peu près les mêmes il
y a il y a Rennes non il y a Grenoble
Toulouse Lyon Montpellier là ce qui est
vraiment ce qui est vraiment inquiétant
c'était un vrai lion un berceau de
l'ultra gauche
il y a beaucoup de militants d'ultra
gauche à Lyon c'est un des c'est un des
versions de l'ultra gauche en France le
le ce qui est intéressant c'est en fait
ce qui est ce qui est ce qui est
intéressant les forces de l'ordre
aujourd'hui c'était reine pourquoi
Rennes parce que Rennes il y avait eu
depuis le début du des Journées
Nationales d'action contre le projet
réforme des retraites il y a
chroniquement des échauffes fourrés à
Rennes vous gardez en mémoire quand même
que ce que la dernière c'est soldée par
trois CRS blessés dont un qui était
enflammés par des cock Molotov qui était
l'incident le plus grave à répertorié
sur l'ensemble du territoire national et
puis et puis Nantes parce que Nantes là
pour le coup il y a énormément de c'est
un gros c'est un gros un gros fief aussi
de l'ultra gauche et c'est inquiétant
parce que notamment de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes
et il y a
parallèlement à la manifestation
tenue par les syndicats une seconde
manifestation qui est prévue ce soir une
marche aux flambeau justement
officiellement appelée marche aux
flambeau dans lequel il y aura toute une
galaxie qu'on m'a décrite comme étant
composé ou on attend en tout cas des
antifas des anticapitalistes des
anarchotonomes des féministes des échos
guerriers d'extinction rébellion enfin
vous voyez à peu près le le comment
dirais-je le pas mal d'activistes voilà
c'est ça voilà le nombre de profils des
participants informations de notre
concert du fil Delta Nicole triolaire
qui dit que
selon les données collectées
actuellement par le flic data donc par
Le Figaro on compte pour l'instant dans
126 villes de France
251.000 manifestants contre 508000
samedi dernier à cette heure-là c'est
donc un peu plus que nous le fait le
Nicole le solide Nicole un peu plus de
50 %
de baisse
il y a une nouvelle info effectivement
je peux poser la question tout à l'heure
sur la jeunesse parce que il y a eu un
nouvel appel aujourd'hui des
organisations de jeunesse donc avec une
volonté de de bloquer les facs mais
est-ce que là on sorte pas ces
organisations là en tout cas ne sortent
pas aussi à la nature même de de la
cause à défendre ou à pour fendre c'est
quelque chose qui est quand même touche
même si on voit des jeunes dans les dans
les cortèges même si certains ont
l'entendait ici disent oui mais elle a
une retraite ça nous concernera toujours
et puis ça peut concerner nos parents
nos grands-parents etc est-ce que quand
même là il y a pas un effet de
des appartenance quand même par rapport
à ce genre de cause alors on pourrait
imaginer effectivement que que les
jeunes se sentent pas concernés par par
ce problème parce que finalement les
retraites c'est pas forcément comme
préoccupation ils sont jeunes ils sont
de choses à faire non demeure pas moins
qu'il y a quand même un certain nombre
de jeunes qui dort déjà on a compris que
la valeur travail va changer de nature
notamment depuis peu la pandémie elle
l'a prouvé le rapport au travail s'est
modifié et il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui
disent en tout cas moi je ne
travaillerai pas jusqu'à 64 65 et 10
pourquoi pas 70 ans donc il y a quand
même des gens qui sont concernés par
cette par cette question mais au-delà de
ça il faut quand même bien comprendre
que cette manifestation la totale est
conçue comme ça par les services qui
analysent un peu les mouvements c'est ce
mot de retraite est un mot-valise
derrière lequel il y a beaucoup d'autres
rancœurs c'est comme ça que c'est
analysé par les services c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment la France la France des
déclassés
la France des sous-préfecture la France
des zones des zones blanches où il y a
plus d'hôpitaux
où il faut prendre sa voiture avec la
carburant qui coûte très cher pour aller
au supermarché cette France finalement
qui n'est plus écoutée par Paris et qui
n'est pas il coûte plus écouté par par
les élites quincarnent
les gens qui sont actuellement pouvoir
en tout cas aux yeux de des manifestants
nous dit c'est les routiers s'y mettent
le pays sera bloqué est-ce que il y a
une crainte à ce niveau là bien sûr bien
sûr évidemment tout à l'heure on disait
mobilisation dans le secteur ferroviaire
et des transports évidemment ça c'est
une des grosses et en évoquait le
spectre d'une paralysie pourrait
participer à cette paralysie évidemment
outre le blocage des des raffineries et
donc des pompes à essence dans un second
temps des opérations escargot voir des
blocages comme on en a connu pendant
de précédentes manœuvre contre
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites est-ce qu'on s'attend un
retour des gilets jaunes ah les gilets
jaunes alors les gilets jaunes
jusqu'à maintenant ils essaient d'une
manière ou d'une autre de surfer sur ce
sur ce mouvement mais ils ne sont pas
meneurs ils ne sont pas
ils essaient de reprendre justement en
région on va peut-être retrouver
d'ailleurs les images là on voit
actuellement les images de la bassine
mais qui était le point de départ de
manifestation à là on est passé un peu
voilà on va repasser aux images cette
fois-ci de l'arrivée Place d'Italie où
on voit quand même encore que que le
cortège éclaire se met c'est d'ailleurs
le titre vers une mobilisation en baisse
que l'on trouve en tête de Home du en
tête de la page d'accueil du site sur Le
Figaro.fr pardon je vous ai coupé mon
cher Christophe sur les gilets jaunes
vous dites il y a en tous les cas une
volonté il y a une
[Musique]
de la part de
des mouvements de venir se greffer et de
revenir parce qu'en fait sur les gilets
jaunes ceux qui sont encore gilets
jaunes on va dire c'est les plus endurci
c'est ceux qui n'ont jamais lâcher
l'affaire et donc ils essaient par tous
les moyens de de récupérer le le
mouvement alors il y a eu des appels il
y a 15 jours 3 semaines notamment à
reprendre les ronds-points à retourner
sur les ronds-points comme comme au tout
début du mouvement à l'automne 2018 ça a
pas pris il y a eu des appels de gilets
jaunes à
occuper les têtes de de manif ou là où
il y a là où on voit le plus etc mais
les mais les services d'ordre des
syndicats ne les laissent pas rentrer
dans les rangs ils sont pas forcément
très nombreux ils sont un peu dilués
alors avant dans la masse la main la
même s'il y a moins de monde mais ça
reste quand même ils sont quand même un
peu moins
l'impression de force et là récemment
des gilets jaunes retirent leur gilets
jaunes on a vu beaucoup de gilets jaunes
qui retirent leur gilets jaunes pour
essayer de se mettre au côté de des
potentiels et métiers qui eux sont vêtus
de noir donc là c'est récemment la
dernière manip c'est ce qu'on a vu mais
aussi parce qu'en fait ils essaient des
choses pour pour continuer l'action mais
en tant que gilet jaune je suis pas
certain qu'on ait une marée jaune en
mars à travers le pays je crois pas la
fièvre jaune est derrière nous la fièvre
jaune est derrière nous cette belle
formule et vous avez pas encore nous dit
que vous avez pas encore dit que la
rotatouille flambeau peut-être une
retraite au flambées ce soir en tous les
cas apparemment c'était la crainte j'en
appelle également au calme sur le site
du Figaro là les les invectives fusent
et
si ça continue je vais demander au
modérateur de bannir les insultes et
donc de bannir ceux qui les aimaient
donc vous pouvez débattre mais il y a
pas
regrette pas et en tout cas c'est la
charte de modération du Figaro et on
débat et on débat avec des arguments pas
avec des insultes et justement au
modérateur du Figaro là de bien être
vigilance sur ce sur ce plan là et si
c'est le cas on
bannira comme le dit il exige la charte
de modération du Figaro
comment on envisage le 7 mars vous
disiez tout à l'heure c'est ça qui est
intéressant
il y a
en tout cas on tape sur une rupture du
front syndical à ce moment là
avec la avec la modération avec la
justement la mobilisation et la
radicalisation du mouvement
est-ce que on pense que ça ce mouvement
prendra est-ce que on se dit encore bon
c'est un scénario il faut s'y préparer
mais c'est pas forcément sûr
il met en revanche les les plus dures
semblent extrêmement déterminés et on
s'attend véritablement à des lendemains
qui des chantent à partir du 7 mars ça
c'est une c'est une évidence dans les
dans les secteurs qui ont été identifiés
par les analystes de ministère de
l'Intérieur à savoir le secteur des
mines et de l'énergie on en a parlé le
carburant les raffineries et avec aussi
des opérations des stages
sur la livraison de de l'électricité
voir des opérations Robin des bois où on
va donner des gens
c'est on coupe pas
l'électricités
beaucoup plus populaire et c'est bon
parce qu'en fait l'idée c'est que quand
paralyse de pays quand quand on arrête
la circulation des trains alors que les
gens partent en vacances etc
il faut pas qu'il se retrouve avec la
France contre eux parce que le principal
argument des syndicats c'est de dire la
France est contre le projet si la France
tout d'un coup change de
d'état d'esprit on a vu récemment là qui
a eu un sondage aujourd'hui qui est
passé
sur les sur les réseaux et qui fait état
de presque six Français sur 10 qui sont
pour une pour des pour un blocage du
pays en
mars expliquer Bernard salomones lundi
sur le plateau de point de vue c'est que
on peut avoir 6% 6 60 % de Français qui
sont favorables aujourd'hui mais dès
lors que le blocage se fait on peut
justement avoir moins de 60% de baisser
à partir du moment où la chose devient
effective et voilà c'est je voulais
exactement venir à ça
mais en fait
cette analyse me semble assez juste dans
la mesure où à partir du moment où on va
s'approcher de l'échéance et que ces
blocages va toucher des gens en direct
la popularité des grévistes la
popularité des bloqueurs va
périr de manière assez rapide donc
ils sont obligés quand même de ils vont
aller jusqu'au bout on le voit bien
[Musique]
mais à un moment ils auront l'opinion
publique qui finira par se retourner
contre eux le savent déjà donc c'est
quand même une partie c'est une partie
extrêmement risquée pour l'instant les
syndicats je trouve ont retrouvé une
espèce de
légitimité parce qu'on a pendant très
longtemps on a dit avec les gilets
jaunes c'est fini les représentants les
organisations professionnelles sont
mortes etc etc on a vu parmi les dans
les premiers jours de mobilisations que
c'est pas véritablement le cas ils ont
mobilisé beaucoup donc là ils vont
monter d'un cran donc ils vont durcir
cristalliser la colère mais en
cristallisant la colère ils vont ils
risquent de se prendre une partie de la
France silencieuse de face
et donc effectivement un fort mouvement
syndical mais qui risque d'être
rompu en tous les cas la France syndical
qui risque d'être rompu après le 7 mars
et une une économie qui risque d'être
hors circuit à partir de cette
période là c'est des prévisions du
service de renseignement et c'est ce que
vous nous disiez c'est quand même deux
choses qui sont importantes de voir et
de savoir donc et qui permettent de
mettre en perspective également ces
images là où on voit un petit peu plus
de monde dans les dans les rues d'Albi
mais notamment dans les rues de Paris où
on voyait quand même beaucoup moins de
monde où le
le cortège est arrivé à destination avec
avec trois heures d'avance il y aura à
ça il faut quand même rajouter aussi
quand même le la perspective c'est pas
parce qu'on bloque le pays que les Black
Blocs n'essaieront pas dans les passeurs
de panique on va pas se mentir c'est pas
pour autant que les Black Blocs vont
désarmer c'est-à-dire que ils sont en
busca dans la vie tout à l'heure
en fait le Black Bloc c'est pas c'est un
mode opératoire c'est une c'est une
c'est une stratégie d'émeutes dans ces
Black Blocs il y a de tout on a parlé
tout à l'heure il y a toutes cette
galaxie les antifas les anticapitalistes
dans la gauche radicale la gauche
radicale c'est deux trois mille
personnes deux trois mille personnes et
en fait là eux ils vont tout faire pour
pour passer pour passer à l'action à un
moment à notre il faut quand même pas
oublier que le black box en plus il a eu
le temps de les Black Blokker ils ont eu
le temps de de s'entraîner de monter en
gamme de gagner en technicité il faut se
rappeler que c'est un mouvement qui a
plus de 40 ans quand même les Black
Blocs c'est pas d'hier c'est ça remonte
en Allemagne on appelait ça les
schwarzen block à l'époque et c'était
des c'était la même c'était la même
couleur mais dans de longues différentes
en allemand quoi et après on les a vu
manifester aux États-Unis après on les a
vu arriver en Europe on les a vu
notamment
au sommet de Strasbourg où ils ont mis à
Gênes où ils ont mis dans des sommets
capitalistes les ou de l'OTAN la ville à
sac et là en fait ils sont ils ont bien
rodé leur dispositifs ils ont une vraie
culture du secret donc ils sont
extrêmement difficiles à
espionner à pénétrer un policièrement
ils ont ce qu'on appelle une stratégie
de recomposition perpétuelle c'est à
dire que quand ils sont sur le terrain
il se silhouette et se décidaient ils
s'habille en noir quand elle passe à
l'action il retourne dans les
manifestations parmi les manifestants
pour se rendre anonymes et lâcher leur
affaires et
ils ont ils ont véritablement une une
longue il y a pas longtemps ils ont
profité on va dire une forme de
réticence politique le le
de pouvoir en place n'ont pas voulu
véritablement s'attaquer au Black Bloc
parce que dedans se trouve à des jeunes
et il voulait pas d'incident mais en
tout cas voilà dire qu'il y a le blocage
mais aussi ces gens là qui ne sont pas
là pour pour faire figuration très
longtemps à certains à certains
internautes qui disaient les Black Blocs
et les services de renseignement savent
qu'ils sont et cela arrange l'état bah
apparemment ce qui ce que vous disiez
c'est que c'est quand même plus
compliqué que ça c'est plus difficile à
pénétrer et à et à infiltré même si bon
il y a des groupes d'activistes sur le
sécurité ou parfois infiltré par un
certain nombre de renseignements tout à
fait
je pense que ce serait ce serait un
raccourci un peu dangereux d'imaginer
que que l'État joue
avec les Black Blocs ou manipule les
Black Blocs pour pour faire des râper de
manifestations ils ont absolument pas la
main dessus
dans la mesure où les Black Blocs sont
vraiment dans la culture de de l'ultra
gauche qui est de la ou des arts
autonome qui est celle de la
clandestinité la plus totale il se parle
même pas enfin il se parle au téléphone
c'est éventuellement pour se donner un
rendez-vous mais voilà ça va pas plus
loin
16h32 sur le site du Figaro et sur
Figaro live
une toute dernière question peut-être et
puisqu'on parle des Black Blocs
deux choses première point on a signalé
quelques violences à Lyon et on en
signalé tout à l'heure à Paris il y en a
eu d'autres depuis
quelques là il y a cette histoire de de
panneaux de signalisation
démonter démonter une banque boulevard
de l'Hôpital boulevard de l'Hôpital tout
à fait
à Lyon il y a eu aussi quelques quelques
heures avec les forces de l'ordre et à
Rennes ça a été des bah justement des
militants du bras gauche
qui une fois encore ont investi les voix
cagoulés vêtue de noir et voir les voies
ferrées et ils les occupés pendant un
bout de temps avant d'être délogé par
les forces de l'ordre mais on n'est pas
voyez on n'est pas du tout dans le grand
soir avec paris brûle-t-il non Paris ne
brûle pas il meule pas albinon plus
d'ailleurs comme on le voit sur ces
images en direct c'est là où se retrouve
les leaders de l'Inter syndical Didier
l'allemand l'ancien préfet ça sera ma
dernière question Christophe c'est
nouveau exprimé cette semaine et il a il
affirme qu'il n'avait et qui n'a jamais
voulu tirer sur qui que ce soit il
essaye de rétablir un peu sa légende
le préfet l'allemand il est il est quand
même
[Musique]
je dirais pas qu'il est parti avec du
goudron et des plumes de la préfecture
de police mais en tout cas son image a
été
hélas pour lui sérieusement
abîmé dans l'esprit du public parce
qu'il y a eu plusieurs dizaines de
personnes qui ont été grièvement blessés
pendant la manifestation des gilets
jaunes qui atteignent une rare violence
et mais en face il y avait aussi des
forces de l'ordre qui était touchées le
préfet de cet ancien préfet de police
essaye évidemment de réhabiliter un peu
sa mémoire et son image on peut pas on
peut pas l'embler je pense pas que il a
donné l'ordre en tout cas ce qui est
clair c'est qu'il a je pense pas qu'il a
donné l'ordre de blesser les gens en
revanche il avait après le on s'en
souvient tous après le
après les
les échauffourés qu'il y avait eu au
pied de l'Arc de Triomphe en décembre
le ministère de l'Intérieur 2018 super
bien sûr pas le ministère de l'Intérieur
avait décidé de siffler à la fin de la
partie parce que c'était sa véhicule est
une image tellement qu'à les miteuses de
la France qu'il fallait aller ce qu'on
appelle au contact et donc c'est le
préfet allemand a été l'artisan de de ce
de
d'aller au contact c'est à dire créer
des forces de choc on m'appelle se
souvenant mais les braves de les braves
de la répression de l'action violente la
BRV qui à moto ou à pied allait
allègrement en contact des des casseurs
et parfois des manifestants il faut
quand même savoir que à ce moment-là
c'était très chaud là dans une manif
comme celle-ci on a 20 30 interpellés il
y avait plus de 1000 interpellés à Paris
en décembre en une seule manifestation
les jaunes des commissariats parisiens
mais la masse des gens qui étaient
ramassées dans les rues le préfet
allemand avait pour mandat de de
provoquer un électrochoc dans les rangs
des des gilets jaunes à l'époque pour
essayer de briser un peu cet élan de
colère donc c'est ce qu'il a fait
évidemment ça sa popularité derrière a
pas été au sommet on n'a pas dit merci
beaucoup Christophe Cornavin on aura
peut-être pas à 20 à 30 interpellations
ici à Albi en tous les cas vu l'ambiance
de de ces images avec un cortège quand
même une personne plutôt âgées ce que
vous avez remarqué certains internautes
tout à l'heure mais en tout cas un
cortège extrêmement calme dans les rues
de la préfecture du Tarn et ben on va
pour l'instant faire une pause on vous
laisse en vivre ces images et on va
reparler avec
Sophie de Ravinel du Figaro politique de
ce qui est en train de se passer de ce
tramer à gauche et à la gauche de la
gauche
en ce moment
et dans la perspective du 7 mars allez
plein pot sur les images
[Musique]
on a vu des images de Jaurès et bien
c'est excellent pour vous introduire
Sophie Piet Sophie dravinel spécialiste
de la gauche
au service politique du Figaro bah
comment va la gauche aujourd'hui
[Musique]
à l'Assemblée nationale et très décidé à
se mobiliser visiblement à partir du 7
mars prochain alors précisément entre
aujourd'hui d'ici le 7 mars il y a ce
qui se passe actuellement à l'Assemblée
nationale avant d'y revenir puisque je
vous donne des nouvelles de la gauche
comment va la France insoumise qui est
en pointe dans ce mouvement la France
insoumise et bien tout dépend de si vous
me parlez de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui
était à la tête de la France insoumise
ou de ses frondeurs en interne ou de sa
base qui se demande parfois un peu ce
qui se passe
parmi ces dir donc ce sont trois regards
différents du point de vue de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et bien il a fait un pari le
pari de prendre la main sur ses
opposants internes on reviendra sur la
fronde il a fait le pari aussi de
prendre la main un peu sur la nubes en
refusant d'arriver à l'article 7 et le
suspense reste encore entier on en
parlera aussi au Parlement et troisième
Paris de prendre la main un peu sur les
les les
syndicats qui eux tiennent la rue très
calmement et de façon assez déterminée
sans heurt on voit que ce qui se passe
sous votre plume et en particulier dans
l'article paru dans les éditions papiers
du Figaro de ce jeudi matin on voit
point donc sous votre plume une
dissension entre les syndicats et les
politiques avec des métaphores
d'ailleurs poissonnière comme chez le
député PC de Seine-Maritime Sébastien
Jumet parce qu'en fait il y a une
répartition des rôles très précise entre
dans la rue pour les cortège syndicaux
les mobilisations les centrales qui
décident dans des assemblées générales
de ce qui va être conduit dans le pays
et la gestion de du pays à l'Assemblée
nationale qui revient au parlementaire
chacun est en dans son rôle depuis des
années depuis que le PCF et la CGT ont
décidé de se conduire distinctement
donc là il y avait que des que des que
des responsables syndicaux il y avait
pas du tout de responsables
il n'y avait pas il n'y avait pas les
points fixes des politiques qui étaient
à Paris et en fait c'est cette
opposition elle est toujours enfin
disons c'était distinction la
répartition des rôles est très clair
très net très respecté Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sauf peut-être un peu par
Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui a voulu bousculer
ça
voilà lui il est à Montpellier
aujourd'hui parce qu'il tient un meeting
ce soir mais pour revenir juste sur les
syndicats c'est vrai que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui il essaye de de il veut
incarner c'est un une disons dynamique
très personnelle il veut un Canet
incarner
prendre le la sur cette opposition il va
être celui qui incarne majoritairement
cette opposition la réforme des
retraites parce qu'il a saisi très bien
que on était dans un moment assez
exceptionnel où la gauche était
totalement unie où l'opinion publique
était majoritairement selon les sondages
opposés à cette réforme aussi et que
même au sein du gouvernement s'acclive
et donc Jean-Luc Mélenchon lui il veut
bordéliser l'assemblée pousser son
avantage jusqu'à donc la dissolution et
c'est un peu l'opposition
qui recherche Mélenchon il veut vraiment
des solutions et il pense que
son épingle du jeu de revenir plus que
Marine Le Pen autant en tout cas
avec elle peut gagner plus de députés à
la faveur d'une dissolution et de
nouvelles élections pour ça oui il se
pense capable de de mener de lever et
c'est pour ça il est dans cette
dynamique là et c'est vrai que comme
Emmanuel Macron ne l'exclut pas non plus
lui il veut une dissolution choisie
contre Mélenchon qui veut une
dissolution subie enfin qui évolue faire
subir cette dissolution donc il y a une
espèce de nouveau de bataille qui émerge
on verra bien où on en sera demain
vendredi à 23h59 si cet article 7 sera
étudié ou non est-ce que ça changera
beaucoup de choses sur la mobilisation
dans la rue moi j'en suis pas convaincue
il y a une bataille de l'opinion qui se
joue là entre les syndicats et les
syndicat des politiques et la gauche
alors il y a une bataille d'opinion
c'est-à-dire que déjà entre les
syndicats et le pays et une bataille
d'opinion et je pense que c'est ça
explique en partie le choix de ne rien
faire jusqu'au 7 mars le 7 mars étant
aussi l'après vacances scolaires et donc
il faut que l'opinion suive parce que ça
va être dur et donc gâcher en plus les
vacances scolaires c'était où disons
partir dès maintenant pendant les
vacances scolaires c'était saliéné une
partie de la population
pourquoi PS et PC on retiré leurs
amendements donc on était à 11000
amendements
on attend nous sommes donc jeudi à 16h
et on attend encore que 16h45 pardon
à 16h45 et c'est vrai que les insoumis
de il y a 5 minutes n'avait encore pas
retiré leurs amendements ils en ont
combien oh ils ont demandé des centaines
voir des milliers ils les ont pas encore
retiré ils ont dit qu'ils allaient être
ils disent qu'ils l'ont qui vont le
faire
ce soir pour permettre la discussion là
on est il faut savoir qu'on est après
l'article 2 alors on est entre l'article
2 et on veut arriver à l'article 7
homologue du service politique me disait
tout à l'heure que effectivement ça va
très vite une fois qu'on a retiré donc
mais là quel est le est-ce qu'il y a un
débat est-ce qu'il y a une volonté de
discuter de l'article 7 avant demain
avant le débat sur la motion de censure
déposée par le RN de la part de qui de
la part de de la France insoumise la
France insoumise ne souhaite pas arriver
à l'article 7 ne souhaite pas le débat
parce qu'il considère que
il ne le souhaitait pas après est-ce que
c'est là où Jean-Luc Mélenchon est en
train de de mener sa bataille en interne
il a affiché qu'il ne voulait pas y
aller est-ce que il va y avoir une telle
pression de la nupette sur lui qu'il va
être obligé de les retirer peut-être
mais je pense que ce qu'il est en train
de calculer c'est que on y arrive pas
malgré le fait qu'il retire ses
amendements c'est à dire qu'il compte
sur l'obstruction voulue par LR et par
Renaissance puisque le gouvernement
lui-même selon la nupesse n'est pas
enfin la nuit pèse considère que le
gouvernement lui-même ne veut pas
débattre de cet article 7 comment
vont-ils argumenter le fait qu'il ne
vautront pas la motion de censure du RN
parce qu'il considère que cette motion
de censure n'intervient absolument pas
au bon moment que si elle doit arriver
elle doit arriver à la fin des débats
c'est-à-dire une fois que le texte sera
parti au Sénat qu'il aura été débattu au
Sénat il y aura une commission mixte
paritaire ça va revenir à l'Assemblée
nationale sauf enfin après on verra si
c'est votre départ décret ou non mais
c'est à ce moment là à l'issue lorsque
tout a été débattu qu'il peut y avoir
le choix par la nupaisse de déposer
cette motion qui est une façon de dire
au gouvernement nous voulons vous
stopper jusqu'au bout la e considère que
le RN
des choisit de déposer cette motion à un
moment qui n'est pas le bon au milieu
des débats uniquement si on en croit à
la nubes pour se faire entendre alors
qu'il ne dépose pas d'amendement par
exemple sur les 1200 euros il faut
savoir et c'est très intéressant cette
bataille des 1200 euros qui est en train
Sophie c'est le montant
le montant de certaines retraites
minimum c'était une promesse du
gouvernement que tous les Français
bénéfiques initial en bénéficieraient de
d'un minimum de 1200 euros et puis de
retraite par la suite quel que soit leur
carrière et puis les opposants c'est
très fort de tout bord d'ailleurs parce
que elle aime aussi et sur cette
question des 1200 euros pourquoi parce
que évidemment leurs électeurs les
interroge là dessus c'est quelque chose
qui touche vraiment les catégories
sociales
les plus modestes et du coup ils ont
poussé pousser pousser pour essayer de
savoir ce que du soft avait dans ses
bagages sur les 1200 euros on a réalisé
qu'en fait les 1200 euros ne pouvait
être
décerné entre guillemets comme une queue
à ceux qui auraient mené toute leur
carrière avec un SMIC minimum donc ça
retire déjà beaucoup de monde et ensuite
là donc Olivier du soft affirme qu'il y
aurait 40000 francs 80.000 non pardon
attendez je vais 40000 français qui
pourraient en bénéficier ce qui est déjà
quand même très très peu et
la nupes avec Jérôme Guedj le socialiste
et d'autres sont allés au ministère des
solidarités pour essayer d'obtenir des
chiffres c'était ce matin donc dans une
démarche très de communication politique
assez marquante parce que tout le monde
dans les voilà on a beaucoup vu et on va
encore beaucoup voir cette image de de
Jérôme guech devant le ministère des
solidarités pour obtenir les chiffres et
lui affirme qu'en fait Olivier du soft
le ministre donc en charge du dossier
des retraites ce chiffre de 40000 euros
qu'il avance comme étant celui que d'une
comme étant le nombre de Français qui
pourront obtenir à l'armée 1200 euros et
bidon c'est ce qu'avant ce Jérôme Guedj
et que finalement Olivier du soft a
sorti ce chiffre de nulle part enfin eux
affirment que ils n'ont aucune trace de
ce qui peut lui permettre d'avancer que
40 000 Français toucheront 1200 euros
et donc là c'est très compliqué pour le
gouvernement parce que si effectivement
il n'arrive pas à prouver que 40 000
Français à minima toucheront ces 1200
euros ça donne un avantage à la nups et
ça va être encore plus compliqué après
pour le débat au scénar mais ce qu'il
faut si je peux me permettre avoir en
tête pour demain et ça notre super
correspondant à l'Assemblée Wally Bordas
travaille là-dessus c'est à dire que
l'article 7 n'est pas le seul qui peut
bloquer
l'ensemble de cette réforme et ça n'est
pas que la motion de censure aussi qui
pourrait voilà parce que la motion de
censurer du RL le mecs
et ne sera pas voté donc mais ce qui
peut en revanche bloqué c'est que vous
savez que dans ce projet de loi il y a
une partie de recette une partie dépense
demain donc jusqu'à l'article 6 on est
dans la partie recette si jamais il y a
un élément qui doit être voté pour voter
l'ensemble de l'article 6 si cet élément
est rejeté l'ensemble des politique de 1
à 6 pardon si cet élément est rejeté ça
veut dire que la partie recette en
entier tombe et ça veut dire que tout le
projet tombe parce qu'il ne peut pas y
avoir une partie dépense si la partie
recette c'est parti c'est à ça que
notamment c'est life parce qu'on a mieux
compris aujourd'hui grâce à ce que vous
grâce
de effectivement
on a c'est l'intérêt de l'actuel à
assemblée au moins on progresse dans la
connaissance de la vie parlementaire
ce soir il y a des nouveaux meetings
unitaires quels sont les enjeux pour les
uns et les autres il y en a plusieurs
insoumis en tout cas parce que chez les
socialistes les communistes et les
écologistes pour le moment tout va bien
donc les socialistes se sont à peu près
à réconcilier
les écologistes ils sont plus beaucoup
mais ils étaient quand même très divisés
tu vois vous voyez on peut réussir à
malgré c'est comme les trots autrefois
ou l'extrême gauche quand il y en a
trois il y a deux fractions mais là les
socialistes donc ce sont le groupe
parlementaire est assez uni relativement
les écologistes sont partis dans des
états généraux de refondation de leur
partie donc à eux aussi c'est plutôt un
mood relativement
unitaire les communistes aussi opposés
aux insoumis c'est chez les insoumis que
ça pose problème mais donc il y avait un
meeting mené par la fronde interne chez
Jean-Luc Mélenchon avec Raquel Garrido
avec Alex Corbières avec Éric Coquerel
qui sont des des députés de
Seine-Saint-Denis avec évidemment aussi
clémentinotta et François Ruffin qui
sont un peu les deux figures principales
de position évidemment avec les autres
pas forcément moins mais avec des
ambitions présidentielles un peu plus
avancées François Ruffin et
clémentinottin et qui sont en opposition
quasi ouverte en guerre quasi ouverte
avec Jean-Luc Mélenchon et son cercle
restreint qui sont en gros les soutiens
d'Adrien katnas avec en première ligne
manuellement pas oui absolument quel
numéro 2 du mouvement et président du et
donc ces frondeurs vont tenir un meeting
ce soir à Bobigny pendant que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon lui tiendra un meeting à
Montpellier
justement question est-ce qu'il y a des
divisions au sein de la France insoumise
sur l'histoire des amendements est-ce
que toutes les parties par exemple
est-ce que les frondeurs est-ce que les
frondeurs avec notamment François Ruffin
sont favorables au dépôt des retrait des
amendements pour qu'on puisse parler de
l'article 7
c'était ce que disait François Ruffin
mais plus que sur l'arrivée à l'article
7 parce qu'il y a des débats qui
touchent à peu près tout le monde c'est
sur la la façon de conduire les
opérations au sein de l'hémicycle avec
le bruit et la fureur du côté de mon
caricature mais des bordements un peu
inutiles on pense au ballon de Thomas
porte d'autres ce serait tout de suite
excusé même si on peut aussi
s'interroger avec Jean-Louis Debré on
vous souviendrez shirakien ancien
président du conseil
quand il était président de l'Assemblée
nationale à chaque fois qu'il y avait du
désordre à l'Assemblée nationale
absolument il était le pion en chef mais
l'assemblée on a l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui les les débats sont un
peu aseptisés il ne vient surtout pas
dire que c'est une bonne chose de
traiter l'un ou l'autre d'assassin un
ministre ou autre mais il vient remettre
un peu en perspective en expliquant que
au sein de l'Assemblée nationale il y a
eu des moments de très fortes tensions
de très grandes violences et qui a une
fonction cathartique de l'Assemblée
nationale
donner une idée il était Jean-Louis
devrait être venu il y a quelques mois
ici même on le reposera peut-être la
question comment l'équipe devenue
l'avocat de la bordalisation à
l'Assemblée est-ce que il y a une
tentation vers la radicalisation d'une
partie en tous les cas de la nupes et en
particulier chez LFI alors il y a la
tentation de récupérer ceux qui sont
radicalisés et qui ne veulent plus voter
et donc toute une frange aussi bien dans
les mouvements climats ça on le voit
plus chez les écologistes mais aussi
chez Jean-Luc Mélenchon et qui sont
jeunes ou pas jeunes mais qui ont dit CD
de rompre avec
la pratique politique le vote évidemment
et donc de de
renouer avec
nous enfin de nouer d'essayer de
convaincre voilà que la pratique
politique n'est pas forcément
enfin je veux dire que la radicalité
peut habiter la politique c'est
compliqué
c'est compliqué parce que je ne sais pas
s'ils arriveront à convaincre qui que ce
soit qui est en rébellion avec la
société à venir voter dans les yeux la
vie politique telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui ne me semble pas de nature à
les convaincre de venir de revenir voter
est-ce que ça sera ma dernière question
on comprend justement vous parliez des
écologistes et quel est leur position là
actuellement comprends pas trop leur
position sur la question des retraites
on les sent assez en retrait son jeu de
mots pas vraiment en fait c'est pas
qu'ils sont en retrait c'est qu'en fait
ils sont un peu éteints par la stratégie
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ça c'est
intéressant c'est à dire on entend que
les opposants du clan de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et c'est son objectif il veut
être celui qui lead mais en fait
Sandrine Rousseau elle aussi elle a eu
des propos très étonnants à l'Assemblée
elle a déposé un amendement sur une
histoire de feuilles de salade un peu
ridicule elle a tenté de faire des coups
enfin ridicules ou rigol selon qu'on
considère selon le jugement qu'on peut
anecdotique
et mais pour tenter de se faire entendre
et en fait ils ne se sont pas tellement
fait entendre parce que Jean-Luc
Mélenchon était là les siens avec Sophia
chikiru avec sa façon de et des tensions
qu'on a rencontré avec walibardas entre
eux entre soumis et voilà les
écologistes de toute façon ils veulent
apparaître comme les radicaux
raisonnables d'une certaine façon et
c'est vrai que Marine tondeelier c'est
quand même elle qui a parlé de la ZAD de
transformer l'Assemblée nationale en ZAD
des milliardaires de et donc elle a eu
une stratégie de communication pour
tenter de passer la bande du son ou
justement qui est tenu par Jean-Luc
Mélenchon elle y est arrivée c'est de la
petite enfin c'est une tactique parce
que finalement elle est assez
conventionnelle marine tondeuse ne vient
pas elle elle est pas conventionnelle
mais elle est un peu apparatchique quand
même aussi elle vient du terrain mais
enfin c'est pas c'est pas c'est plutôt
une Radical Chic radical populaire et du
coup c'est un petit peu de la
communication même si chez elle et une
vraie volonté de faire évoluer son
mouvement mais mais voilà on verra si ça
prend je retiens votre votre formule sur
la Radical Chic plutôt que la radicale
peu plus haut c'est peut-être parfois
une critique qui est faite contre le
contre les verres en particulier et une
partie de la gauche en général merci
beaucoup Sophie dravinel dans tous les
cas nous avoir raconté un petit peu les
coulisses de ces débats de ces
dissensions également du côté des des
bancs de la nupesse et
sur
l'avancée des débats à l'Assemblée on va
faire un tour par Place d'Italie voir
comment quel est l'ambiance
effectivement apparemment en tout cas
selon les images qui nous parviennent
que vous voyez en direct une ambiance
assez calme comme le disait
Vladimir Garcin tout à l'heure dans le
live texte et puis on va faire le point
justement sur les l'impact économique de
tous ces mouvements avec Marie Viso
plein pot
[Musique]
17h on est pour 15 minutes pas une de
plus pas une de moi avec Marie viseaux
chef du service France au Figaro
économie
bien sûr il y a un bouclage on continue
de suivre toutes ces questions et le
Figaro économique est en première ligne
sur toutes ces questions des retraites
depuis le début de toute cette séquence
Marie merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
merci beaucoup d'être avec les
internautes du Figaro vous répondez on
va répondre à leurs questions à leur
commentaire également sur la page
Youtube du Figaro peut-être un point sur
les grèves
on parle beaucoup de manifestations
depuis le début de l'après-midi mais
c'était aujourd'hui une journée de grève
on a vu on voit on voit encore sur ces
images c'est un petit peu plus clairsemé
Place d'Italie même si c'est différent
de la place de la Nation au musée Sion
samedi donc
une baisse au niveau de la mobilisation
même la CGT le reconnaît à Paris
est-ce que c'est le cas également au
niveau des grèves alors oui
effectivement ça baisse c'est un peu à
l'image de cette place de l'Italie en
gros et en moyenne parce que évidemment
chaque secteur à ses propres chiffres on
a divisé par deux les taux de grève
depuis la dernière journée de
mobilisation qui était déjà elle-même en
recul par rapport à la première ou même
à la deuxième journée donc effectivement
ça c'est souple ça s'essouffle il y a
des raisons très objectives c'est que
quand on fait grève on n'est pas payé
et donc on en est quand même déjà à la
quatrième journée donc on y réfléchit à
deux fois avant de poser un jour de
grève il y a des il y a des salariés qui
poussent des jours de RTT
qui s'organisent un petit peu
différemment mais pour tous ceux qui ne
sont pas payés pour les jours de grève
parce que c'est quand même le cinquième
jour c'est le cinquième c'est le
cinquième vous avez raison j'ai dit le
4e c'est le 5e jour en de pouvoir
d'achat évidemment
j'ai bien compris
et puis effectivement le cinquième jour
il faut être très motivé pour faire
grève
[Musique]
le rapport des services d'info de
renseignements que ce qu'on craint c'est
que tout ça finisse par mettre
l'économie hors circuit donc c'est pour
ça que je vous pose la question pour
finir ma réponse donc
macroéconomiquement ça ne pèse pas sur
un point de PIB vous voyez mais comme
j'ai dit ça il y a à peu près 15 jours
et que je me suis pris une rafale et
c'était assez légitime de mail de patron
de
petite entreprise de commerçants qui
m'ont dit mais madame vous n'imaginez
pas nous ce que ça nous coûte de ne pas
avoir nos salariés parce que les
transports n'ont pas fonctionné n'ont
pas fonctionné ou d'avoir été obligé de
fermer nos commerces parce que on
n'avait pas le personnel donc oui ça
pèse à l'économie ça ne pèse pas en
termes de PIB en termes de grosses de
grosses masse de valeur de création de
richesse mais individuellement pour les
gens qui sont concernés par une journée
d'activité plus ou moins perdue oui ça
ça compte c'est plutôt microéconomique
que Macron
[Musique]
c'est des images nous sommes
actuellement où nous sommes en direct ça
Paris Place d'Italie et donc et donc
voilà le 7 effectivement il joue leur va
tout et les syndicalistes il y a encore
entre 1 et 2 millions de personnes dans
la rue ce jour-là le gouvernement ne
pourra pas faire passer cette réforme
reste à voir mais c'est en tout cas ce
qu'ils disent
vous venez de signer un article très
intéressant et qui t'a retrouvé donc
dans l'édition papier de ce jeudi bien
sûr sur le Figaro économie ce genre
d'image ce genre de mobilisation a un
impact sur l'image de la France à
l'étranger et à l'impact apparemment
négatif
inévitable en terme d'image oui
la question qui se pose c'est est-ce que
en terme de business c'est à dire en
termes d'investissement étrangers ce
genre d'images fait peur aux
investisseurs pour l'instant c'est un
peu tôt pour le dire
mais ce qui est sûr alors ce papier
auquel vous faites référence c'est une
étude qui est publiée tous les ans par
la Chambre de commerce américaine en
France qui interroge les filiales
françaises d'entreprises américaines
installées en France sur la perception
que les Américains ont de la France et
là on est en train de rentrer dans une
période charnière
quand qui est que en gros quand tout va
bien que la croissance se tient que il
qui fait du mal les Américains sont
capables de passer en route là l'image
en trois semaines les Américains ça va
peut-être commencer à leur poser
question ils sont capables de passer
outre certains défauts français que sont
sa fiscalité
dans une moindre mesure son coup du
travail parce que les choses se sont
quand même largement améliorées et son
climat social quand ça va moins bien
c'est à dire que l'Europe est en crise
que il y a tous les stigmates de la
guerre en Ukraine l'inflation qui sont
encore très présents et bien les
investisseurs américains quand en plus
ils ont ce genre d'image sous les yeux
et ben tout ce qui est le tout ce qui
compose les points noirs de la France
ressortent considérablement dans leurs
inquiétudes c'est à dire que ah là là en
France bah c'est vrai qu'ils ont une
fiscalité qui est pas très bonne c'est
vrai qu'ils ont une bureaucratie qui
nous a toujours embêté et puis c'est
vrai que le climat social
et ben il est ce qu'il est en France
donc en termes d'images c'est assez
désastreux on va voir si ça se
transforme en terme de business et ça ce
serait bien plus compliqué parce que
c'est intéressant parce que il y a de
quand on regarde cette étude c'est qu'il
y a de gros il y a de plus gros points
faibles que j'allais dire en tous les
cas aux yeux des bien sûr des
investisseurs américains
donc effectivement bien particulier mais
il pointe quand même plus facilement
quand on regarde l'étude les procédures
administratives le coût de la main
d'oeuvre et le coup de licenciement par
exemple tout à fait ce qui est censé
être des sujets qui avaient été traités
ces derniers ces dernières années pour
que ça aille mieux et et donc de manière
à la fois rationnelle irrationnelle il
les ressortent et il les remettent en
avant sur le devant de la scène voilà
c'est point noir français dont on ne
parlait plus depuis plusieurs années
resurgissent
avec ce climat social pareil qui était
avec un peu relégué parmi les
inquiétudes chez les chez les
investisseurs ben voilà ça revient vol
pas vu nous dit c'est sûr que entre nos
syndicats nos charges fiscales et
sociales et 35 heures les industriels
n'ont pas envie de venir c'est pas
complètement vrai ça joue pas
la France en Europe la France en Europe
reste sur la première marche du podium
de l'attractivité c'est-à-dire que en
relatif oui on a des défauts mais ça
veut dire que les autres n'ont plus que
non plus que nous et c'est pour ça que
ce genre d'images
qui est mauvais pour l'image on ne sait
pas encore si ça va se traduire dans le
business parce que quand même en France
on a des atouts on a une main d'oeuvre
qualifiée on a des infrastructures on
est géographiquement parfaitement
localisé en Europe
on a un écosystème d'innovation et
technologique qui plaît beaucoup aux
investisseurs voilà donc il y a tout ça
à mettre en face qui fait que oui la
France reste très attractive
d'ailleurs ce qui est intéressant c'est
là c'est un article également de jeunes
tissus Timsit qui est dans la même page
l'édition papier du Figaro de ce jeudi
qui raconte comment la la presse
étrangère voilà la France et ce qui est
très frappant c'est que il y a un écart
de vision entre les pays anglo-saxons et
les pays du Sud en tout cas donc à lire
ces grands étrangères
éclatés conclu voilà à dire du mal de la
France c'est c'est culturel historique
traditionnel les Anglo-Saxons adorent
critiquer au club Le Figaro
international dernièrement dans un dans
une émission sur le Royaume-Uni on dit
que les Anglo-Saxons l'un des sports
favoris c'est dire du mal des Français
plus que les Français auraient plutôt
d'en dire des Allemands mais mais pas
autant que les Anglo-Saxons disent les
Français effectivement les dans les
autres pays les cités l'Espagne mais ils
n'ont pas du tout ce petit plaisir à
aller chercher la petite chose négative
des Français
non c'est très anglais
effectivement pour relativiser ça et
avant de secteur qui lui dit amazon est
bien sûr et bien en France et
alors ce qui est vrai c'est que le délit
télégraphe parle des grèves comme un
sport national mais enfin en ce moment
on voit bien que au Royaume-Uni c'est
l'hôpital qui se moque de la charité
pour eux ils ont très longtemps regardé
la France que comme
enfin les grèves français parce que un
truc un peu extraterrestre maintenant il
se confronte à ces situations là et ils
vivent ce que nous on a régulièrement
vécu et de manière assez exponentielle
par rapport par rapport à nous ce que
vivent les Anglais en ce moment c'est
pas très facile mais si on parle encore
des investisseurs étrangers est-ce que
pour eux la réforme des retraites
précisément et prioritaire
alors les réformes structurelles sont
prioritaires
la réforme des retraites en fait partie
et c'est surtout plus que la réforme des
retraites en elle-même un gage que la
France c'est encore se transformer
ils ont longtemps eu cette image d'une
France qui
ne saurait plus se réformer se
transformer se rendre plus compétitive
et la réforme des retraites plus que la
retraite en elle-même est un peu
l'incarnation de tout ça et ne pas aller
jusqu'au bout de la réforme des
retraites serait pour les du point de
vue de l'étranger encore une preuve de
l'inertie
de la France de la politique française
du peuple français
le problème
parce que l'inflation la lutte contre
l'inflation leur paraît pas plus
prioritaire
je pense que c'est un tout le contexte
le contexte économique
générale et regarder d'assez près et
scruté par les investisseurs étrangers
ils nous comparent
les pays européens ils regardent de très
près le contexte économique les manières
de gérer l'inflation les manières de
rehausser la compétitivité effectivement
l'emploi les licenciements et les
retraites tout ça fait partie de d'un
panorama global qui est assez scruté des
investisseurs étrangers si je reviens à
la situation sociale maintenant il y a
un phénomène qui est intéressant c'est
le regain d'adhésion pour pour les
syndicats c'est un phénomène que qu'on
voit qui depuis en tous les cas un
phénomène fort
ce genre de manifestation effectivement
rebooste reboost les adhésions dans les
syndicats c'est assez vrai à chaque fois
alors c'est un peu plus d'ampleur cette
fois-ci c'est vrai pour tous les
syndicats on la CFDT c'est vrai s'en
sort particulièrement bien cette fois-ci
mais oui la contestation
remobilise du point de vue syndical
alors il y a un phénomène également très
frappant que l'on voit quand même depuis
le début de cette séquence c'est l'unité
syndicale et le maintien d'unité
syndical est-ce que comme on commence à
l'entendre et comme le semblait comme le
disait en tous les cas Christophe
Cornavin est-ce que le 7 mars sera le
dernier jour de l'unité syndicale c'est
un petit peu ce que je vous disais tout
à l'heure en fonction de la journée et
de l'ampleur de la journée du 7 mars
[Musique]
le soir du 7 mars
la CGT peut décider que il faut aller
plus fort plus plus
loin plus vite plus c'est un peu
difficile de savoir ce que je ce qui va
se décider ce soir ce jour-là mais
effectivement c'est peut-être le jour de
la fin de l'unité syndicale qu'est-ce
qui va se passer
avec vous et la ça serait peut-être pas
mon micro mais le
dire la question c'est qu'est-ce qui se
passe avant
cette mars là les syndicats
l'intersyndical va tout faire pour
préparer pour mettre le paquet sur cette
journée c'est ça
opération cette mars le plus de monde
possible
vraiment le pays s'arrête vraiment on
veut que les on veut les syndicats
veulent que les 64 ans soient tirés
c'est vraiment ce jour-là le 7 mars
qui sera à l'oeuvre sous cette marque ne
puisse laisser d'autres choix au
gouvernement que de l'artillerie c'est
c'est ce sont leurs paroles c'est à dire
que peut-être que face à deux millions
de personnes dans la rue le gouvernement
estime estimera qu'il n'a pas à retiré
son 64 ans en tout cas eux
œuvre au fait que il est tellement de
monde
que ce soit presque une obligation pour
le gouvernement de faire ça c'est leur
ambition
des syndicat voilà et en tout cas les
images qui parviennent donc de la place
de d'Italie à Paris qui est le la
destination finale de cette
manifestation parisienne qui a réuni
moins de monde c'est ce que dit en tous
les cas la reconnaît la CGT tout à
l'heure qui dit 300 000 manifestants
contre 500 000 samedi dernier on va voir
quels sont les chiffres officiels dans
quelques instants quand on les aura les
chiffres de la préfecture de Paris
peut-être qu'ils sont encore tombés mais
je ne les ai pas encore vu donc dès
qu'on les a on vous les donne merci
beaucoup Marie vise avec 17h15 vous
voyez on a tenu on a tenu le Paris merci
d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir répondu
également aux questions et aux
commentaires des internautes du Figaro
on va regarder maintenant ce qui va ce
qui se passe et ce qui est en train de
se passer sur les réseaux sociaux
comment cette journée a été suivie
comment ça se mobilise également sur les
réseaux sociaux avec Romain coursier et
en attendant ben encore des instants
d'ambiance Place d'Italie à Paris plein
pot
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
17h18 vous êtes toujours avec nous on
est toujours avec vous on est très
content d'être ensemble pour commenter
cette nouvelle cette cinquième journée
de mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites journée moins suivie moi en
tous les cas avec beaucoup moins de
monde dans les rues on va avoir dans un
instant ce qu'il en est sur les réseaux
sociaux avec Romain coursier bonjour
Romain bonjour Vincent responsable
justement du pôle social réseaux sociaux
au sein du pôle social media du fil on
s'occupe des réseaux sociaux en tout cas
avec les excellents Jean-Baptiste Sener
et Charles Darche et les excellents les
nombreux excellents membres et de ce
pôle qui constitue l'un des pôles de
l'excellent pôle audiovisuel voilà j'ai
fait un pari de dire à chaque fois
excellent donc il faut que tu vois c'est
gentil voilà
sur le cas d'excellence et notre
objectif
romain est-ce que on a observé la même
tendance sur les réseaux que celle qu'on
a observé au plan social et celle qu'on
a observé dans les rues est-ce qu'il y a
eu moins de monde moins de mobilisation
sur les réseaux sociaux et ben la
journée sur les réseaux sociaux est à
l'image de la place d'Italie qu'on a vu
et qu'on voit à l'écran beaucoup moins
de monde beaucoup moins de réactions de
messages de tweet en tout genre les
médias ont on posté à peu près comme
d'habitude mais les utilisateurs on va
dire lambda ça a été le
hashtagrave 16 février était même pas
dans les 10 dans les 10 sujets en top
tendance sur Twitter par exemple donc
vraiment beaucoup moins ça a été
beaucoup beaucoup moins suivi que que
les dernières fois beaucoup moins suivi
que les dernières fois est-ce que
pendant les manifestations en tous les
cas il y a eu un certain il y a eu des
postes il y a eu des il y a eu un pic ou
bien non il y a pas eu de coup d'éclat
clairement la semaine enfin la dernière
fois on avait vu
quelques quelques petits quelques petits
coups d'éclats or les heures avec les
forces de l'or mais on avait vu les les
membres d'attaque les altermondialistes
d'attaque faire une petite chorégraphie
quelques happenings de ce genre cette
fois-ci vraiment vraiment presque
presque rien en tout cas pas grand chose
pas grand chose sur le mouvement sur les
réseaux sociaux en tous les cas en
termes de quantité alors comment quand
même ceux qui se sont mobilisés en tous
les cas s'ils sont pris pour se faire
connaître et
quels éléments on a pu voir et découvrir
aujourd'hui alors je vous retrouve
saillie est bloqué alors ça c'est le
grand lycée parisien dans le près du
près du Trocadéro exactement donc
première particularité aujourd'hui c'est
que si la mobilisation baisse on a
l'impression que certains lycées sont
plus sont plus bloqués que la dernière
fois notamment donc Janson de Saïd dans
le dans le assez bourgeois 16e
arrondissement de Paris
des lycées qui fait blocus facilement
donc c'est voilà c'est pour ça que je
vous l'ai mis en exergue j'en sonne ça y
est aujourd'hui était bloqué on a un
autre lycée bloqué
dans Paris donc là c'est la marque c'est
Lamartine exactement lui a été bloqué
plus souvent exactement c'est pour ça
que j'ai mis Janson en premier mais donc
voilà des lycées bloqués donc ça c'est
la première particularité ce qui est un
petit peu plus remonté que les dernières
fois en tout cas sur les réseaux sociaux
délicieux bloqué et également d'autres
d'autres secteurs qui ont été mobilisés
alors effectivement comme aujourd'hui
moins de mobilisation on parle déjà de
la prochaine étape en fait beaucoup sur
les réseaux sociaux le fameux 7 mars et
le premier jour de la grève illimitée et
ce qui peut faire peur ça c'est
intéressant parce que normalement le 7
mars c'est tout l'enjeu on en a parlé
toute l'après-midi c'est pas forcément
un jour de de grève un début de grève
illimité c'est un début de grève
générale mais tout le monde n'est pas
d'accord sur ce plan là en tout cas ceux
qui poussent pour une grève illimité se
font se font entendre se mobilise sur
les réseaux et donc c'est pour ça que je
vous ai mis cette dépêche AFP qui parle
d'une possible greffe des éboueurs alors
la grève des éboueurs c'est une des
grèves qui incommode le plus le les
citoyens nos amis marseillais qui nous
regardent savent de quoi on parle
puisque j'ai souvent eux les plus
touchés pour des durées souvent assez
longues donc voilà possiblement les
éboueurs peuvent rejoindre la lutte à
partir à partir du 7 mars peut-être
avant de regarder ces autres ces autres
images et les commenter comment ça se
enfin quelle famille de personnes
mobilisées on trouve sur les sur les
réseaux sociaux
on trouve souvent du militant de gauche
voir d'extrême gauche on va avoir des
messages
des appels à la mobilisation des
messages vraiment contre assez
globalisant c'est à dire contre le
patronat contre la bourgeoisie contre
les puissants c'est on essaye de
rassembler on va dire
le plus de monde possible avec des mots
clés
est-ce que les partisans de la réforme
ou les opposants ces manifestations les
opposants au grève se mobilisent et se
mobilisent autant alors honnêtement en
tout cas aujourd'hui ils ont ils ont été
complètement aux abonnés absents et
c'est ce c'est ce qu'on le voit le moins
les gens essaient d'ailleurs une
capacité des réseaux sociaux les réseaux
sociaux c'est très fort pour s'indigner
pour protester mais alors pour pousser
une réforme pour pour aller dans dans le
sens du gouvernement c'est c'est
beaucoup plus difficile d'engranger une
dynamique sur sur les réseaux sociaux
même ceux en fait généralement même ceux
qui peuvent être pour la réforme s'ils
voient un message qui va dans le sens
vont pas forcément le le liker le
commenter le partager ils vont être
d'accord alors fort intérieur mais ils
vont pas réagir parce qu'ils ont aussi
peur de se faire ensuite tacler par par
les opposants à la réforme alors romain
on regarde peut-être une autre image que
vous avez sélectionner là justement vous
voyez l'image de RER oui je voulais je
voulais revenir sur cette image qui date
d'hier et qui bosse pas mal aujourd'hui
pourquoi parce que les gens sur le bord
du quai dans les transports en commun et
dans des transports en commun
complètement bandés c'est le grand
classique des grèves généralement et
force cette constater qu'on le voit de
moins en moins grâce au télétravail les
gens n'ont pas on va dire non plus
besoin nécessairement de se rendre sur
leur lieu de travail pour travailler du
coup quand il y a grève tout le monde
prévoit de télétravailler les transports
en commun sont vides et ce tweet est
intéressant ce qui est pas le cas là on
les voit pas ils sont pas
ça ça date d'hier donc hier il y avait
pas de grève et une utilisatrice lambda
donc nous la cuisse qui interpelle
Valérie Pécresse en disant c'est pas un
jour de grève et pourtant le RER est
bondé je n'arrive pas à rentrer dedans
donc voilà c'était un petit peu pour
retourner le grand classique des grèves
où on monte tout le temps des des
problèmes dans les transports en commun
moi je vais en transport en commun vous
aussi à chaque à chaque grève le MES
rames de métro sont deux à trois fois
moins bondés que d'habitude à cause en
raison du télétravail en tout cas on
voit en tout cas on observer qu'il y
avait et que ça fonctionnait et qui
avait en tout cas plus de train sur le
réseau Transilien donc on relève qui
relève effectivement du régions
Île-de-France dirigée par Valérie
Pécresse encore une heure là
effectivement
d'autres secteurs qui sont touchés vers
la grève et effectivement
celui-là on n'avait pas encore prévu
alors ça concerne un petit peu les
Parisiens surtout les touristes parce
que si les
usagers des transports en commun les
gens qui vont travailler peuvent trouver
une solution dans le télétravail pour
les touristes à Paris
pour le coup la grève a un impact ils
peuvent pas aller visiter la Tour Eiffel
un des plus beaux monuments de France
voir du monde qui était complètement
déserte aujourd'hui donc une image assez
au final assez sympathique quand on la
prend comme ça puisqu'on la voit on la
voit rarement aussi aussi vide cette
tour Eiffel image intéressante parce
qu'elle corroborent justement ce que
disait tout à l'heure Marie Viso sur
l'image qui est renvoyait par la France
et par certains
lieu emblématique et comment la Tour
Eiffel ne pourrait pas être un séduire
emblématique aux étrangers et aux
investisseurs étrangers via les
touristes donc effectivement ça risque
également selon les choses à avoir un
impact une dernière image une dernière
image on y va pour le bon on là on est
dans les manifestations et avec trois
jeunes filles qui reprennent pour ceux
qui ont la référence la campagne du
gouvernement sur les économies d'énergie
que chacun peut réaliser donc avec le
slogan je baisse j'étais un jeu décale
et elle elle parle évidemment de la
réforme des retraites qu'elles ne
veulent pas avoir arriver donc on baisse
l'âge de départ à la retraite bon
j'étais un et en tout cas je décale je
décale le projet c'est en tout cas la
revendication de de ces manifestants et
effectivement il y a toujours un
floriage de de slogan
en tous les cas effectivement c'est pas
très c'est pas très polémique merci
beaucoup romain coursier de d'avoir fait
partager effectivement cette ces
derniers c'est ce qui s'est dit sur les
réseaux sociaux et puis cette
mobilisation qu'on va continuer de Steve
le suivi 17h28 voilà pour son peu dire
pour la mobilisation on va revenir c'est
la question d'ailleurs du jour est-ce
que la mobilisation qui est en baisse
aujourd'hui va s'essouffler c'est toute
la question qu'on se pose aujourd'hui et
voyez c'est également la question qu'on
se pose sur le site du Figaro le
mouvement social contre la réforme des
retraites est-il en train de
s'essouffler est-ce que vous avez voté
si vous avez pas voté c'est le moment on
en reparle bien dans deux minutes le
temps de faire les changements avec
Vincent très molette Villers directeur
adjoindre la rédaction du Figaro et
éditorialiste au Figaro et également sur
Europe 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà images bonjour à tous Voilà
rebonjour à ceux qui nous rejoignent qui
n'étaient déjà toute l'après-midi sur le
site du Figaro et bonjour à ceux qui
nous rejoignent également qui nous
écouterons sur Figaro radio pour cette
question du jour qui va nous permettre
également de reparler de la mobilisation
lors de ce 5ème acte
de l'opposition à la réforme des
retraites la question du jour le
mouvement social contre la réforme des
retraites est-il en train de
s'essouffler c'est la question qu'on
pose et qu'on a posé sur le site du
Figaro pour en parler et avant d'y
répondre dans Vincent trimer de Villers
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
Figaro bonsoir Vincent
la mobilisation en tout cas est en
baisse sur toute la France est-ce que
c'est si étonnant
non on s'y attendait et c'est à dire que
cette manifestation est une
manifestation intermédiaire entre deux
d'autres journées de mobilisation qui
sont annoncés comme plus amples et plus
plus dur
celle-ci c'est un peu la fin d'un
premier cycle de contestation sociale
qui est un cycle inspiré par les la
volonté de Laurent Berger de manifester
de façon pacifique
en nombre on a vu dans beaucoup de
villes moyennes qui avaient beaucoup de
monde
et
ça on voit que cet exercice là arrive un
peu à son terme il est-ce qu'il a obtenu
des choses c'est ça qui est compliqué à
voir c'est à dire que si jamais le
travail législatif se faisait de façon
continue et structurée on pourrait dire
que ces manifestations ne servent à rien
mais comme à l'Assemblée il y a un
désordre peut-être plus important que
dans la rue
c'est pour ça que ça nous oblige à être
prudent c'est à dire qu'on peut
considérer que le mouvement social est
en train de s'essouffler dans sa forme
de manifestation massive est-ce que on
peut considérer que la réforme des
retraites en a fini avec la contestation
et que ça va aller tout seul ça me
paraît quand même beaucoup beaucoup plus
compliqué surtout quand on voit ce qui
se passe à l'Assemblée oui parce qu'en
fait c'est très difficile en fait de
comprendre enfin d'imaginer ce que va
devenir ce débat parlementaire une fois
qu'il quittera l'assemblée il va aller
au Sénat puis une CMP peut-être il
reviendra certainement et dans quel
climat on sera là je ne sais pas ce
qu'on voit quand même aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il y a un grand jeu
d'hypocrisie dans lequel se rejoignent
quasiment toutes les les
fragments de l'Assemblée nationale qui
consiste à dire que l'on veut examiner
le texte l'article 7 donc avec le recul
d'âge de 62 à 64 ans tout en souhaitant
de tout son cœur de ne pas l'examiner
Jean-Luc Mélenchon voudrait qu'il ne
soit pas examiné pour pouvoir mobiliser
le 7 mars en disant nous avons été
victimes d'un rap démocratique
le la majorité
et hésitante mais il y a beaucoup de
députés qui sont dans des
circonscriptions où il y a beaucoup de
manifestants qui tant qu'à faire s'ils
étaient pas sur la liste en ces temps
malheureusement les gens
c'était pas sur la liste ça des votant
ce serait mieux elle est sa réglerait
leur division interne en fait il y a que
le rassemblement national qui aurait
intérêt à ce que se voter lieu parce
qu'il pourrait ainsi pointer du doigt
notamment le groupe LR en disant vous
voyez vous êtes des opposants en carton
vous avez soutenu la réforme de celui
qui vous a combattu et qui vous a réduit
à 5%. donc tout ça fait que
l'incertitude même si il y a tous les
outils pour Elisabeth borde pour arriver
à terme à faire adopter cette réforme
l'incertitude elle existe plus à
l'assemblée que dans la rue dans la rue
on verra le 7 mars c'est-à-dire est-ce
que le 7 mars
créer un nouveau souffle
installe une nouvelle tension sociale et
politique par la dureté et la et
l'aspect spectaculaire de la France à
l'arrêt ça on le verra mais c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la fin d'un cycle
et il y a presque une forme
d'indifférence pour ce mouvement alors
que la tension reste concentrée sur ce
qui se passe à l'Assemblée alors on va
pas rentrer dans une question de trop
technique ou trop de spécialistes mais
il y a quand même un élément central sur
ce genre de manifestation sur ce genre
de mobilisation sur ce genre d'ailleurs
de dossier c'est la bataille de
l'opinion première question d'abord
quand on voit
ces images et se calme quand même qu'il
y a eu global que l'on a observé cette
ambiance Pacifique qu'on a observé
depuis le début de la séquence et par
rapport à ce qui se passe à l'Assemblée
nationale est-ce que justement ce
contraste n'a pas favorisé les syndicats
et
nous a pas avantagé dans la bataille de
l'opinion
politique de ces cinq journées
manifestations c'est la naissance d'une
force de gauche réformiste
opposé à Emmanuel Macron mais distincte
du mélenchonisme c'est vraiment ça que
l'on voit apparaître et quand on étudie
il y a une note de la Fondation Jean
Jaurès très intéressante sur qui
manifeste dans les sous-préfectures et
en fait c'est une sociologie de gauche
qui n'a pas de débouché politique
c'est-à-dire qui a dû croire à Macron en
2017 mais qui n'y croit plus et qui n'y
croira plus jamais puisque elle est
opposée à cette réforme mais qui ne veut
pas des formes
outrancières et provocatrices de la
France insoumise donc ça c'est ce que
Laurent Berger a réussi et qui ce qu'il
a réussi même de façon magistrale
puisque jusqu'ici ce qui
comment dire caractériser le macronisme
c'est qu'il avait des opposants qui par
leurs excès leur provocation leur
incapacité à gouverner
faisait qu'il pouvait agréger autour de
lui ce qu'on appelait le parti de
l'ordre le parti des gens raisonnables
forme de partie du bon sens
pour cet exercice de la réforme des
retraites ça marche pas parce que pour
le moment les défilés et les cortètes je
vous montre des gens qui sont opposés
mais qui sont raisonnables qui ne font
pas peur à l'opinion qui ne cassent pas
et qui ne crée pas un désordre qui fait
que l'opinion se dise bon voilà ça
suffit il faut arrêter mais cette
sociologie
enfin en tout cas en quoi d'abord
consiste cette sociologie du réformisme
de gauche qui ne se reconnaît pas chez
chez d'abord la gauche manifestante
traditionnelle avec pas mal de d'agents
de la fonction publique les gens que les
syndicats parviennent à
fédérer et puis on voit beaucoup ce
qu'on a appelé pendant le covid la
première et la deuxième ligne donc ce
sont des gens qui exercent des travaux
physiques organiques c'est-à-dire qui
qui ont besoin de se déplacer là où ils
travaillent
qu'arrive caissier enfin un certain
nombre de métiers
de livreurs enfin de métiers physiques
qui ne peuvent pas être télétravés donc
déjà qui échappe à une vision un peu
parisienne ou un peu des métropoles qui
consistent à dire maintenant le travail
on peut le faire un peu chez soi il ne
profite pas de cette réorganisation du
travail et en plus ils ont l'impression
d'avoir porté le pays pendant les deux
années de covid et c'est vrai qu'ils
étaient plus sollicités que ceux qui qui
pouvaient rester chez eux et donc il
voit comme récompense
à cet effort le fait qu'ils doivent
travailler d'autant plus donc c'est ça
le qui s'ajoute à la mobilisation
habituelle des forces syndicales et
c'est alors ces gens là je sais pas ce
qui veut tout ça peut-être certains
votent-ils pour le rassemblement
national d'autres pour le parti
communiste mais il pourrait composer une
force militante pour ce qui était la
gauche socialiste en fait est-ce que
vous voyez cette sociologie là
régénérer
la gauche
politique mais elle nous rappelle
qu'elle existe c'est et c'est parfois le
l'utilité d'un mouvement social c'est de
de faire
sortir dans la rue des gens dont on
pensait à beaucoup d'enquêtes d'opinion
voire de résultats électoraux qui
n'avait plus de signification politique
et sociale mais c'est des choses qu'on a
vécu sur des sujets complètement
différents quand la manifeste surtout
pour tous sorts dans la rue contre
la loi Taubira pour le mariage entre
personnes de même sexe beaucoup de gens
découvrent une force en fait politique
et sociale qui dans les radars et des
sondages et des élections n'existaient
pas où étaient réduites à des
pourcentages absolument dérisoires alors
là c'est pas on va pas faire des
comparaisons entre les choses qui ne
rien avoir mais mais les mouvements
sociaux participent de ça et là ce qu'on
voit parce que ce qui se passe dans les
sous-préfectures et d'ailleurs les
leaders syndicaux l'ont compris
puisqu'ils sont à Albi aujourd'hui
et quand même ne peut pas être écarté
d'un revers de la main en disant comme
le disque dans la République c'est
toujours les mêmes et ça ne change rien
non là il y a un phénomène militant et
politique qui mérite d'être analysé
est-ce que ce sont justement ces fameux
genre ordinaires qui sont notamment des
cris par Christophe Christophe qui lui
bah c'est une partie mais c'est pas
alors c'est là où c'est compliqué c'est
à dire que à ce cette sociologie là
apparemment avec les travaux qu'on a ce
que nous disent nos reporters qui vont
sur place qui suivent les manifestations
ne s'agrègent pas une partie de des
catégories populaires notamment celle
qui votent pour leur rassemblement
national ou celle qui ont pu pousser
soit de façon symbolique soit de façon
physique en hyper participant le
mouvement des gilets jaunes pour le
moment les indépendants les artisans les
son peu ou pas dans les cortèges donc
peut-être sont-ils en accord avec ceux
qui manifestent mais ils ne prennent pas
part
à ce mouvement là le mouvement social
contre la réforme de retraite est-il en
train de s'essouffler c'est la question
en tous les cas qui est posée
aujourd'hui sur le site du Figaro on y
revient et puis on est en fait une
extension du domaine de la réflexion
avec Vincent tremolet de Villers de la
rédaction du Figaro vous votez vous
pouvez voter on va on va regarder
dans quelques minutes le résultat du
vote à l'heure où on se parle moi
j'avais une autre question puisque le
mouvement est en train de en tous les
cas à baisser aujourd'hui en termes de
manifestants qu'en nombre de grésistes
quel intérêt avait l'intersédical de
maintenir cette mobilisation en pleine
vacances deux régions de de zone sur
trois qui sont en vacances scolaires
je suis pas leader syndical donc je je
vais pas parler à leur place mais on
peut penser qu'un mouvement de cette
ampleur a besoin de de point d'étape et
donc les manifestants ont besoin de se
compter ont besoin de se regarder aussi
dans leur mouvement social et on a
besoin d'entretenir la flamme entre
entre deux
de moments qui seront des moments
beaucoup plus
paroxystiques et là le prochain c'est
celui du 7 mars donc on peut analyser ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui en disant c'est
un reflux mais je pense que si on
interroge ceux qui sont opposés à la
réforme ils diront c'est pas refus c'est
un entraînement c'est c'est on reprend
des forces pour après et ce qui est
certain c'est que l'assemblée n'a pas
démobilisé par la clarté de son choix
un certain nombre d'opposants notamment
ceux de la CFDT qu'ici l'article 7 avait
été voté clairement franchement avec une
majorité 149,3 assez large
de 7 mars aurait pas été la même
histoire là pour le moment on n'en sait
rien parce que ça change toutes les
heures mais si demain à minuit l'article
7 n'a pas été examiné et donc c'est le
texte par au Sénat sans qu'une majorité
démocratique ne se soit dégagée en
faveur du recul de l'âge de 69 64 ans et
bah la capacité mobilisatrice des
opposants restera pleine et entières
pour le 7 mars est-ce que
vous pensez donc dans ces conditions
j'allais vous demander est-ce que ce
recul aujourd'hui peut avoir un impact
sur l'opinion a priori bon on n'est pas
devin mais c'est plutôt un impact nul je
pense qu'il pense qu'il y a une
lassitude dans l'opinion aussi c'est à
dire que vous avez une part importante
qui milite vous avez une part qui n'est
pas dérisoire même si elle est très
minoritaire qui est quand même favorable
à ce texte et je j'imagine alors je
voudrais documenter ça de façon précise
mais qui a aussi beaucoup de Français
qui sont pas emballés à l'idée de
travailler deux hommes plus
[Musique]
la majorité de des internautes qui ont
répandu à l'heure on se parle et être un
peu plus de 30000 mais la question est
encore posée et elle est posée jusqu'à
sur le site du Figaro en tous les cas
jusqu'à ce vendredi
jusqu'à ce jusqu'à ce vendredi 17
février à environ midi donc vous pouvez
continuer voter si vous avez pas encore
voter
à ce pour répondre à cette question du
Figaro merci beaucoup Vincent
traversière d'être venu sur le dans les
studios du Figaro bien sûr on vous dit
on vous écoute demain matin de bonheur
de bonne humeur 7h53 sur exactement et
après on pourra bien de la réforme
pourra rebifurquer ensuite sur le site
du Figaro pour écouter la matinale de
Radio Classique et qui est à partir de
8h10 merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivi
merci d'avoir été en direct chers
internautes et vous restez avec nous
dans un instant dans un instant point de
vue qui est présenté sur le site du
Figaro en direct à 18h ce jeudi et bien
sûr si vous les écoutez sur Radio Figaro
radio excellent animé par haute Cérès et
bien les programmes continuent à très
vite sur le site du Figaro